pour cette dernière ronde du tata steel
en compagne de souffre qui a fait un
véritable marathon de stream pendant
cette dernière quinzaine bravo à toi
tout fogiel wirth a été énorme et y est
sadique mais lui l'air sympa
le kevin salut à tous et bienvenue sur
le stream tout cette dernière journée du
tata steel
2022 donc on a déjà deux de champion 1
kevin hin exactement on en a parlé un
dans le challenger doerig aisin vraiment
on a beaucoup parlé hier
est ce qu'on doit représenter
magnus carlsen le vainqueur du tata
steel bon il a déjà gagné sa partie bon
ça c'est peut-être est pas sa plus
grande victoire un sloop de la quinzaine
est sûre on rappelle que du boeuf
il a le coc vide donc il n'a plus le
droit de jouer et du coup passa
légèrement
faussé
le tournoi mais ça pas eu d'impact sur
la première passant par fausse et voilà
il ya eu déjà eu des victoires gratuite
contre lui l'a dernièrement appel que
tout faux en a profité pour me prendre
un seul de cette belle manière voilà je
le rappelle quand même
c'est le jeu c'est le jeu comme on comme
on dit et sinon blague à part bah ouais
carlson il a juste été énorme stouff du
coup il mérite complètement avec toi et
du coup ça y est en termes de lots hier
stouff m'a fait une bonne blague à la
fin du stream disait il ya tant qu'y
avait il a gagné que 3 points sur scène
je vais pas y croire sur le moment et
bien sûr par a plus b j'ai eu la
démonstration mathématique de stouff
voilà est du coup j'ai rien pu faire
j'ai rien pu opposer et c'est juste
qu'en faisant un tour encore cinq
victoires 7 nuls depuis trois mois il
perd des points à chaque nul donc du
coup c'est difficile de vraiment un
monte quarantaine franchement il a un
mérite de ouf enfin il est tellement
haut maintenant
tellement au dessus que c'est devenu
hyper dur de monter
donc il y avait des parties ont commencé
exact là on voit que on rapporte et
guiry ben ça va être la petite grünfeld
de guéry et ongles je sais pas présenter
les matchs un petit peu qui nous
attendent aujourd'hui est ce que tu
attends toi à tout fait ce qui aura
beaucoup de nuls tu penses comme dans
les petits au point en amateur ou la
dernière ronde et moins combative
ce possible avoue mais alors déjà en
avant de forest champions
celle là elle va jouer charmant petit
coin de forêt des arbres lui joue tout
le temps il adore les bornes plus
maintenant il adore les sables et blanc
il a il a des blancs il joue un jour qu
elles mêmes locaux donc je pense qu'il
va tenter sa chance voit donc pour moi
je pense correspondent kivu il l'aurait
veut hâter lent donc du coup ses portes
il va jouer grand des news grande et liu
ce prénom touda bon dodaf nuls rapide
des deux jours contre attaque et blanc
ici grand des lieux s'y fait pas un très
bon tournoi et l'année blanc ça
m'étonnerait pas que wendel aux joues
solide et que in nul rapide ce
et
normalement et les joueurs aussi grande
elle aussi peu tout envoyer mais le
contact se fait qu'on sait pas trop à
quoi çà mais il
quand il sera difficile mais bien en
tant que ça termine pas et du coup c'est
un peu différent de la normale on n'est
pas la route un oubli ou quoi donc donc
du coup c'est pas je veux pas ne vois
pas un très gros combat dans celle-là
rapport guy ben je pense qu'on va en
france on va voir un petit peu encore il
a bourges doit-on oui en tout cas on en
voit une grande salle non c'est plutôt
pour jouer quand même après on va voir
le choix de rapports quoi ouais
puisqu'après ya quand même beaucoup de
façons de faire un nul à cannes dans la
bonne
convard commencé à soulever jusqu'à 23
il pas remplir les vides je vais prendre
un temps donc on va voir un peu ce qui
va se passer
c'est saisissable
[Musique]
nancy comme quoi il a montré sa montre
voilà bah je pense évidemment prêt tu
vas jouer lui c'est un petit jeune n'y a
pas de raison qu'ils passent nul et les
consignes du coach tout fondu être clair
par rapport à ça mais si bien qu on a vu
que maintenant ils étaient en train de
s'affirmer et au delà d'être plus de 27
c15 ligue en même
temps comment ça va être une grosse
partie bonjour fait d'eux les deux
joueurs veulent jouer donc ce soit une
partie et ça va être sympa de voir tu
vois la moyenne d'âge sur l'échiquier
les cas elles gagnent pas très élevé un
exact donc ça au récent et puis c'est
cool quoi donc mac dont 412 bon or cet
hybride covit donc que fait partie car
c'est à gagner le bol de pas voir
carlson sur la dernière ronde puisqu'il
a quand même là et je pense que carlson
il aurait aimé jouer parce que bath les
blancs et pour lui c'est une opportunité
en plus l'accès blanc quand même parce
que c'est dangereux pour nous c'est
super sympa de regarder car scène pour
vous c'est super sympa c'est le numéro
un mondial tout ça mais en fait c'est
juste la qualité de jeu qu'il a déployés
ces partis sont vraiment très
pédagogique en plus à chaque fois stouff
c'est pas hyper calculatoire alors ça
peut dériver sur des gros calculs mais
on a surtout vu que c'était l'excellence
du jugement le jeu de construction la
stratégie ou quinzaine fait la
différence et c'est c'est génial a
montré c'est génial a commenté
du coup ces petites déceptions de pour
la voir sur cette dernière ronde
forcément way
et m'hamed carbonneau m'hamed caruana
dans la foulée stouff est ce que tu
entends d'un méga juana
france tous âges où marfin millan fut
longtemps et karoui karoui la part des
médias là il rêve de gamin procédure est
devenu un rapide ça prend deux tournois
il peut pas gagner le tournoi et de
sécuriser la deuxième place pas bête non
plus et ça parce que je vous rappelle il
ya quand même des prix un enjeu donc
s'est passée ta les prix s'étalent est
pris sur apprendre d'autres on pourra
regarder ouais un tuteur à bon prix je
pense dans les scènes ainsi on verra
après et donc je serai pas étonnant non
plus si vraiment il veut sécuriser les
prix
que qu'il fasse une rapide etc les
blancs le carbone à ilan et noir car
voilà doit
bafin si armand et le noir y ait du mal
à vraiment refuser l'annuel ce niveau là
même 45 dr karina exact enfin j'ai vu la
conférence de presse il disait que que
la nulle comme cannes est un très bon
résultat mais il allait jouer un petit
peu et puis caronna aussi voulait jouer
donc du coup bas il ya eu un beau fail
quoi j'ai donc tout le monde
voilà à voir et sinon kayak invididu
crois pas du tout qu'il a remis hier
très
de manière très moche
de caruana aussi
mais c'est pas la même chose ils ont un
coût et l'autre c'est un armement mais
pour moi vidéo qu'il a perdu une partie
hier
assez dramatique et créative aussi
d'ailleurs mais carrick se défoncer
mais je pense que les deux joueurs ont
vu que tout va se terminer
wagon mois il reparti chez karine visite
il n'y aura pas de parti chez caruana
mamet et il n'y aura pas de partis
pas tard qui sait c'est vraiment pour
moi
pour tester un petit quelque chose avec
les blancs les
mais je pense ça va travailler en qu'il
n'a pas en tout cas je le vois comme ça
est ce que est ce que tu veux pouvoir
les prix ou parce qu'il ya les prix ou
pas
sur
l'exigent aurait tenté avec sa mort
c'est quoi ça l'application format
c'est pas grave on regardera une pause
et on vous donnera les prix exacts non
mais on nous apprend que je pouvais vous
pouvez chercher les points oui on peut
se reconnaître
ok bon du coup on vous envoie oui alors
par rapport au score où il mamediarov
rapport et son égalité
11 ennuis qui secure quasiment deuxième
place à mamediarov parce que rapport
rapport les outils déjà les jours avant
guéri il a les blancs à un rythme qui
guérit pas être facile non plus en non
non on annule les sur deux d'être
troisième est le grand show 22e pour moi
bon on peut voir un combat de soi même
est grave il est comme ça mais quand on
vous des prix prenant à partie des gros
prix elle en parle quand même de
plusieurs genres dizaines de milliers
d'euros
[Musique]
généralement on enfin ça arrive qu'on
soit moins combatifs
ont pour l'instant
ils ont froid le financier mais mais bon
ils sont pros dans leur démarche quoi
c'est ça aussi la csa
salut aragon voix cariat kinvi liszt et
ils ont choisi l'ouverture quasiment la
plus égalisant de possibles donc ça
devrait pas jouer très longtemps
mais j'ai assez étonné je trouve chez
huawei hasard j'ai mis 22 forez
contrechamp tendent au hasard oui ok
voilà
le hasard fait bien les choses forcément
m de long qui est là
et du coup ce qui est assez marrant
c'est qu'on a un début long traditionnel
stouff le début londres c'est cette
structure là en triangle le triangle de
la somme islam mag et blanc avec le fou
qui est sorti et on a l'habitude de voir
cavaler des deux cavaliers f3 d'options
c3 et le fou va toujours en d3 on peut
le dire
dans ses débuts de londres avec la
structure aussi ce dessin qu'en face
c'est très rare de le voir en deux c'est
le choix de devant de forest il ya tout
de suite fait réfléchir ça me chante
landes ou deux on peut le jouer sur les
systèmes fille en quête au pour
différentes raisons et sur les systèmes
comme celui qu'on a devant les yeux
c'est vraiment étonnant comme comme des
six visages fictivement
donc là
pas pour l'instant l'explication qui va
il va sûrement arriver quoi clairement
ça a
donc qu'à king dit ouais ça ça fait un
nul rapide je pense grand des lieux ce
parti pour jouer
au final
ouais tu es là c'est la baston mais ça
peut encore faire nul avec un choix
dernier théorique si vous voulez on peut
vous montrer les propositions et voilà
c'est une scène classique où ça on voit
avec le grand roque les noirs dans les
siennes comme ils ont balancé leur
pioncer ils font généralement le petit
voire est au milieu mais en tout cas on
pourrait se retrouver dans les positions
de rock opposé même si à chis on va voir
mais ça
indique généralement est pas obligé tout
de suite de roquet parce que si on a
peur des g4 g5 qui arrive donc ça va
être une partie assez funky
vraisemblablement
cette petite partie entre
entre grands des lieux et houda pas si
grande et lyon s'il a fait une soirée
mais regardez il ya l'air d'avoir mal au
crâne
grosse soirée il était au café et là je
pense qu'il essaie de se rappeler de ces
lignes peut-être y lit ou
on va voir à ce niveau là bien préparé
je pense qu'il réussit des niveaux à ski
[Musique]
dans sa cage il va devoir ou ce soir
quoi voilà c'était pas vraiment pas le
moment la dernière ronde au mieux non ba
s'est retrouvé face quoi donc
mais déjà grande et lui c'est ouais il
est
laid comment dirais-je visiblement ou
alors il fait du cinéma mais bon ça
serait assez étonnant le bluff de ce
tous ouais le fameux bloc de stouff
c'est reparti là avec avec un schisme et
c'est pas le coup qu'il avait dû
préparer vraisemblablement on voit
qu'ils planchent va voir combien de
temps il va à m as well as joué son coup
mais visiblement donc pas être si près
que ça
lorsque l'armée en tout cas ça qu'est ce
que je sais pas trop j'ai pas trop
rétro ses positions
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ici avec le
blanc on doit essayer plutôt deux
manches en relève six mètres le four en
hk je n'aurais pas donné mon fou
j'aurais joué fourrage 4
ouais
parce qu'on vend quoi h4
fou 3 tu peux vraiment peut-être
m'ennuyer
avec
g4 tu vois donc fois ce cadre par défaut
hélas hélas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas puisque pas nécessairement envie de
jouer j'ai cinq dans cette position avec
les noirs même si des fois ça peut être
bien de mettre le fond j'ai certes mais
pas avec un pion d61 vous voyez dans
cette structure là le pion serait trop
faible
et en tout cas bonne chance à toi rania
qui nous dit je pars jouer en ligue en
ligue sd des vosges du coup c'est super
voilà il va se faire
et ronde interclubs aujourd'hui donc
tous les joueurs tous les joueurs de
clubs français qui ne sont pas en
première division vont aller jouer leur
petite partie ou grosse partie
d'ailleurs en faire comme les pros et du
coup bon courage à tous voilà peut-être
qu'ils vont nous regarder de leur
voiture en déplacement après ça sera de
jouer au
hockey du coup un chiffrage 4 je connais
pas bien la théorie non plus on peut
dire c'est que
c'est que le fou est moins souple
maintenant ans quand il est en h4 peut
plus revenir sur cette diagonale pour un
moment il peut y avoir des g5 à tout
moment aussi
c'est un thème et fawcett etc par contre
le défaut c'est comme utiliser ça
rapproche le point de faire sec g4 g5
voilà stouff pour ce petit on fait un
petit tour des échiquiers
aller et on ira voir aussi marc landry
maori qui s'est vraiment refait sur la
fin de tournoi qui était vraiment pas
loin de gagner hier et dans un tout
petit i'm not au sens où n'était pas
hyper mal autant il a il a perdu son
avantage son gros avantage en essayant
de sécuriser son gain et des fois on
joue un peu moins précis dans ces
conditions là et on sait pas c'est pas
si grave ce qu'il a montré vraiment de
belles choses sur la fin de tournoi se
trouve le petit jeune
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut aller voir
tient une belle ouverture
une belle ouverture qui a l'air de
également peut-être car iachini veux
jouer je sais pas on va voir mais
on est dans quelque chose de assez
classique écart iachini là
il a légèrement surpris vie dit
peut-être
ouais mais bon avec je fous les deux
natives jouer sinon
on voit plutôt
classiquement d ed
dans cette position les petites calmes
on va me le dire
voilà
être grand show j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vont ils vont bien s'entendre
classiquement stouff on voit plutôt des
et des héros kefu g5 et eu hélas à
jouer à base d'oeuf ou des deux et puis
bon le pion doit pas être comestible de
faire [ __ ] en c3 pour gagner le pion
central est toujours dangereux quand les
cases noires sont ouvertes de donner
votre case noire
laure noualhat par beaucoup mais bon
cadre à un pion la structure de noir
serait complètement et à 7 6 7 6
détruite mais
d'avoir pensé 3 français 3 2 dé prendre
quatre on peut imaginer vous aussi deux
fois mieux vaut prendre 6 points 4 et
tous les kids est un
con me désiste rectifions faible mettre
en mode de jeu consiste
et moi je pense à mener à sa ville de
partir ça commence plutôt que les autres
jours on vous avait prévenu la dernière
ronde à midi alors que les autres jours
c'était 14h et salut à toi tu chasses
évidemment je bondis c'est sûr là ils
remarquent d'amadeus à présent dans le
tchat ça commence tôt aujourd'hui
rappelez vous que ce conflit il est 8
heures 8 heures c'est chez toi je trouve
ça il est 8h du mat et en classe ce
string pas depuis chez moi je suis allé
chez mon pote parce que moi j'ai des
points de connexion que c'est moi bon
pour tout vous dire
au sucre je vais être content de te voir
débarquer ont été prévenues en même
temps j'imagine non mais il est pas loin
il dort à
800 points gmac est celle de double je
suis venu vous certains lui dont elle
peut pousser un
jeu taillé culinaire on s'est couchés à
3h30
ou bleu à 7h ce matin c'était
trop content de te voir aller aller
bosser comme ça quand
enfin bourbon est ce que tu fais des
light mais oh oui nous achetions ça
mérite bien un petit peu là mais gros
525 maintenant j'en ai mais j'en ai oui
c'est vrai au tout départ quand je
faisais du stream j'ai eu pas mal de
problèmes de connexion parce que je suis
pas fibrés chez moi stouff et du coup
obligé d'utiliser une solution parce que
finalement c'était pas fibrés c'est
quasiment impossible de stream et n'y a
pas beaucoup de solutions par mois à
cannes j'étais pas fibrés j'avais une
très bonne connexion gt gt partiel chez
chez sfr j'avais genre allemande est là
le plus gros sans le meilleur truc et
j'avais une j'avais une très très bonne
connexion
pas trop loin d'une borne cité en ville
et tout ça ce qui n'est pas mon cas
je suis pas très loin de rennes mais
j'habite parraine et la poupe est venu à
fouet non c'est à dire ouais j'avais de
la mézière tu vois donc du coup c'est un
petit village mais les deux communes
c'est le plus proche de rennes et celle
encore plus loin que nous de rennes les
deux sont fibrés ce qui me rend dingue
et ça c'est télé petit les petits
désagréments effectivement ne pas être
dans une grande ville mais du coup j'ai
une solution darling qui a je fais un
peu de pub pour cette pour cette
solution et du coup j'ai internet par
une sorte de parabole hypermoderne
stouff mais autant une fibre est quoi
très moderne mais
voilà voilà pour la petite histoire
on continue le tour des échiquiers parce
que la
rb5 en normes ifrs et non
ça ne passe pas le deuxième coup ah
ouais non non ouais ouais non là je peux
pas parler
non je peux pas parler c'est trop risqué
mais quand même il dit de réfléchir un
petit peu c'est une demie idée peut-être
de revoir et 20 pouces et d'un coup ça
c'est
ce joueur qu'à 20
ans ni grande alliance pour moi il
bluffe pas à chis je fais pas il
réfléchit toujours
si on allait voir
caruana m'hamed ça promet aussi de pas
être aisée
allez on va aller voir
toutes les voir ouais ouais ouais donc
caruana ma mère parce que voilà
et riga et si oui c'était plié 1 hier
puisqu'il a fait nul alors attends je
vais pas de dire de bêtises on va aller
vite fait bon là il se passe pas grand
chose non plus on avait annoncé
régulière
et toujours entreprises à aller voir la
partie et gaz il a neuf et demi et son
le second failli à deux secondes dans ce
tournoi des challengers c'est un
aiguillon à 8 et oubliera 8 aussi alors
qu'erica isi il a neuf et demi voilà et
on peut voir cette partie parce que
visiblement ben marc andrieu il se prend
une préparation ou en tout cas il est il
sans doute très bien préparé lui aussi
marc andrieu mais pas autant kerrigan
ziki à
1h43 à la pendule
impressionnant on regarde un peu se
trouve comment on est arrivé ici elle
est donc ni mesure indienne comment on
l'obtient des quatre cavaliers f 6 et 4
6 voilà cavaliers ces trois fous bekkat
empêche carte indirectement grâce au
clonage
cavalière 3
du classique 1 c'est une des variantes
possibles petit rock
la fougère 5 et dans ses variantes
un peu plus un peu plus rares on fait
souvent ses cinq rapide pour mettre la
pression parce que là où vous voyez qui
a le flou âge mais il ya aussi un retard
de développement du fouet f1 alors que
le roi ici la rocqué le roi des noirs à
roque et pas nous du coup on essaie
d'enflammer la position avec baignoire
avec ses 5
au retour c'est un j'imagine que c'est
un coup un coût théorique
parce que c'est bizarre stouff de jouer
tour c'est un ici
en doute que cela permet tout simplement
de contrôler la présence et 3 à tout
moment et de pouvoir reprendre une tour
il ya peu d'autres idées on peut
peut-être déjà chassé avec 1,3 pense
faire dégommer la structure voilà
comment je comprends ce coup là il
hachey a été jouée
ou h4 pour garder le courage et on a
juste cassé la souplesse du fou comme
dans la partie
de deux grands des lieux et de duda
du coup ici après fo h4 s'éprend des
cats les noirs décide d'ouvrir la pose
d'un voilier prendrait quatre et
maintenant des cinq as well et noir
ouvrent logiquement la pause et à tout
moment aussi le fait d'avoir joué
hashisho h4 je peux avoir un g5
tranchant pour faire un cavalier cadre
de folie
c'est ça reste de l'ordre du possible
dans ce cas là ce serait plutôt
calculatoire eu du beau jeu de
construction parce que c'est anti
positionne elle est vraiment dans ce cas
une préparation assistée par ordinateur
une ligne tranchante calculatoire
parce que c'est pas des baux échec comme
magnus c'est un autre registre et des
échecs un peu à la vache et lagrave
justement où on envoie la boxe
donc il ya eu prise des cinq français 3
pourpre en c3 et j'ai cinq mois il doit
être préparé à 1 souffre parce que c'est
vraiment très tranchant où j'étais sûr
que oui l'idée c'est de prendre de la
dame en fait parce que sinon il y aurait
des fous premier fils éclater la
structure voilà et c'est vrai que je
suis en retard de développement donc
s'il faut que je me batte pour me
développer et il ya eu un joli coup on
pouvait penser à eux trois mais le
problème c'est qu'il ya des cavaliers ou
quatre qui menacent donc tu as préféré
f3 marque andry pour justement balance
est assez pénible se meurent fait comme
la dernière fois stouff va me dire
encore que je peux enlever les flèches
en cliquant mais c'est pas le bug d'aig
avec des collègues elle a l'idée oui
c'est de faire re 4 en prime 1 et 5 a
été jouée par les reagan easy qui doit
être bien préparé et cavaliers b3
logique d'un prend des airs pour
apprendre si on fait un petit bidon
cette position c'est moins grave
peut-être d'être des rockets dans cette
position sans les dames évidemment et là
je suis presque à jouer 4 et tout va
bien et du coup la préparation du joueur
avec des noirs c'est de jouer lui même
quatre pour empêcher mon os 4 voilà la
position j'ai pas visuellement j'avoue
je déteste pas les blancs si vous voulez
parce qu'à la paire de fou mais comment
je sors peu fou f1
la question de la position attention il
ya des cavaliers dessin qui peuvent
arriver à tout moment aussi et d5
benacin vous voyez je peux pas jouer
trois souffre pas si facile à position
en fait tacler les blancs bien sûr
qu'avec les blancs je suis mieux sur le
long terme si j'arrive à passer cette
position puisque j'ai la paire de fou
comme je le disais j'ai même un
développement qui paraît correct
visuellement mais en fait il ya une
menace concrète en fait dans le jeu de
construction l'urgence de ma position
c'est sortir le fouet f1 et sur 3 je
prends cas et des 5
donc j'ai un problème aidez moi je ne
sais pas quoi jouer avec les blancs
et merci 225 il nous fait et il nous
fait le petit point qui a déjà eu match
nul entre mamediarov et caruana voilà
bon il s'est rien passé la vaste cuisine
autant dire you sleep rapporte guy aussi
bon ben voilà on voit on voit les
banques rapport guéri j'étais pas ce qui
s'était passé sur la même nul quelqu'un
à qui dans le même temps moi
et donc voilà donc beaucoup de gens dans
le chat un peu question pourquoi les
joueurs font nul aussi rapidement en
fait c'est en amont du tournoi et puis
il ya plus grand chose à jouer au niveau
des places
et du coup ils ont pour le moment il le
tournoi est longue journée semaine il
faut bien ça que c'est un 13 ronde même
si eu des journées de repos c'est très
engageant ses 1 3 15 jours déjà 1,3
d'une semaine c'est important mais là
quinze jours 13 secondes c'est vraiment
énorme comme tournoi il n'y a pas
beaucoup plus de tournois en matière de
ronde est quasiment le maximum qu'on
voit aujourd'hui le 13 secondes
d'ailleurs j'ai ma simple en tête avec
plus de rondes j'ai joué un seul tournoi
s'est tous fait un championnat du monde
junior où il y avait treize ronde avait
fait un énorme tournoi par contre j'ai
perdu les rondes 12 et 13 du couverts
verres ça fait toujours mal
et du coup je me rappelle de cette
fameuse ronde 13 où j'ai proposé nul
rapidement je pensais que mon adversaire
allait accepter que dali refusé je
deviens complètement gagnant donc ils
meurent propose nul qu'est ce que je
fais ben non non non c'est morte a
décidé de jouer et bien sûr je les ai
perdus que tu vois encore une belle
histoire tu vois l'histoire des grands
joueurs à hu est très combatif j'avais
proposé une ville sympathique à mon
adversaire et refusent ils essaient de
me la colle et il est mal c'est normal
que bah je joue pour lui la colle et
bastien au final
malheureusement ça s'est mal passé on la
connaît celle là un grand classique la
6e manche du cola c'est pas facile en
fait c'est pas facile à cause de ce 3
qui n'est pas jouable non on va
réfléchir en même temps peut-être que
marc landry est en fait ce qui est un
peu inquiétant c'est que donc il
réfléchit donc ça c'est très bien il a
un problème et réfléchie c'est normal
mais le joueur indien enfin s'il connaît
la position puisqu'ils à 1h43 autant il
a tout dit c'est ça lui met la pression
et avec le roi un peu bizarre
ça va vite de ce fait de rentrer dans
les ennuis à cette menace de cas et des
cinq peut-être souffle je verrais bien
un coup comme moi c'est un
droit
1 pourquoi pour partir pour sécuriser
pour faire une cabane
ok mais t'as pas besoin forcément de
faire ça veut dire ton roi en finale il
faut activer un petit peu robes à le
mettre en oeuvre non je laissais leur
lancée là mais s'il ya des points f5 son
honneur pour moi on est pas encore on
enregistre voilà c'est on est en pré
finale alors ce que veut le laisser au
milieu mais attention si on laisse aux
millions peut aussi avoir des problèmes
doc c'est toujours
un peu bizarre ce genre de position sur
son milieu mais je veux pas le mettre en
plus d'être anciens c'est bien sûr une
case mort parce que les lois reuzeau
quand même enchaîné bien je serai encore
plus endettée mais chercherait suroît c1
si tu veux main cela j'ai joué au roi
des deux s'en vouloir hop ça c'est la
magie du direct mais moi j'ai pas envie
de le laisser landais un ccd prologue
est un plan après parce que comment on
sort le foot il faut absolument que je
sorte ce faux f1 je peux toujours pas
faire que trois il va falloir que je
peux être que je bouge fouet mais j'ai
pas envie de sortir partage tout fin
donc alors je fais
pouey f2 pas fait exprès de le jouer
aujourd'hui à précieux l'aca
apprends pas bien horaires etc
alors du coup peut-être fois f2
je remets mon foot 15 noir
ah si simple encore et qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent de
5 tu avais les bd 7000 de
nom mais en fait ou 5 c'est tout à fait
jouable mais il faut regarder faut
vérifier qu'à aider 5 à chaque fois
ces cinq
escales règle et noir j'ai envie d'aller
chercher le fouet f-16 joue cavalier 3
je vois bien ce truc me joëlle roy d2
pour je lui prenne son fou un peu
poubelle au après je venais tour sur la
commune siège pas si mal non exact foot
le foot corpo zezelj en développement là
je bouge monroy genre en c1 donc je vous
tour des huit
sais pas si je menace
de se briser
peut-être que je peux
3com sata pour appuyer là où ça fait mal
pour l'hymne national entourage et
maintenant je te lis comment ça se
passait retour à chaque match donc sous
veut mater la
la
c'est gérard majax à
copperfield
tous types de joueurs voilà
quatre c'est une question h 14 h 15 j'ai
quatre peut-être gk toi-même lasse tout
feu le grand duc la grande classe
- trois tours fc
g4 c'est une idée intéressante que vous
avez envie de percer et pour empêcher g4
ça pourrait se faire mais elle en rêve
un petit peu
way
to fit rigole parce que je suis obligé
d'enlever les flèches manuellement et ça
c'est ça peut faire ça ce genre de
petits bugs mais ok là ça serait parce
que le drame non cette position là sont
pas du tout
de la tête du courant c'est un malin
le roi que vous avez vus s'est fait
chopé au centre là bas le roi il ya un
moment il est débloqué un ferry garros a
offert gare ouais enfin les gaffes du
coup est ce qu'on le fait directement
donc là il ya eu 4 on vous rappelle dans
cette position là parce que c'est pas si
c'est un bon outil a quand même décidé
de la vendre comment annoncer comme des
idées sur hkd j'ai 4 h 5 je prévois
détourage 4-1 prises angers calzatura
ch4 et c'est rentré mais à courrendlin
j'aime pas mais simon roy d'anciens
place et d'avoir un peu de nos quais
c'est que c'est bizarre à l'option 1 3
il est quand même très méchant
donc
faire de soi là il est à la fois pas
autant danger qu'il ne serait avec les
dames sur l'échiquier mais quand même
c'est pas si facile que ça ce qu'on va
acheter le direct
et des bas image ocha 125 qui
apparemment on voit des gens faire le
tour de france
le vélo un neuf et demi sur 13 ouais en
fait non mais c'est pour magnus cherche
que tu mets ça mais oui et riga et 6 et
9 et demi sur douze pour l'instant donc
c'est vraiment un tournoi colossal
doerig asie et d'ailleurs tous nous
disait que même car elles navaient
l'avait reconnu et le trouver à la fois
ouais je trouvais vraiment or un truc
complète faut avant tout les dans toutes
les phases du jeu et et disait qu'il y
aurait bientôt de 1700 lots il ya
beaucoup de monde aubert j'ai vu la
vidéo il ya une vidéo qui est sorti de
2x tremain donc kevin bordi avec avec
cornette ils ont parlé de 2,2 et ghazi
et du coup ben je vais je la regardais
hier le bombo aussi intéressant et la
vidéo franchement elle est hyper
intéressant hyper sympa dans 20 minutes
donc moi je vous la conseille en tout
cas vous êtes sur la chaîne tyc stream
chaîne youtube la vidéo de cordes et
elle est vraiment hyper intéressantes
sont sérieuses et des partis cueillir
higazi à jouer dans le tournoi il
recommandé tu peux voir pourquoi ce soir
reste six spéciales et comment elle
avait quelques parties et c'est hyper
intéressant en tout cas je vous
encourage à aller voir cette vidéo très
sympa quoi est ce qu'on peut dire aussi
c'est que c'est un gros bosseur en plus
puisque la dans la théorie 1
déjà ils proposent ils proposent des
choses à chaque fois la preuve
aujourd'hui a finalement il a réussi à
surprendre marquant qui va pas avoir la
tâche facile je pense dans cette
position quand l'adversaire il à 1h43 il
ya quand même une pression un est pas si
facile humainement parlant cette
position avec le le problème qu'on a
détecté au niveau du roi et il serait
que sur h4 si on essaye de poser des
problèmes au roi noir il ya toujours des
idées de g4
donc pas facile cette position se trouve
quand même
on pourra on va suivre avec une
attention toute particulière cette
partie les intéressants allez on
retourne peut-être dans le ha dont il ya
déjà eu deux nuls 1 le temps qu'on
regarde cette partie de marque en contre
et ghazi celui qui a déjà gagné le
challenger on repart dans le a et on
était souhaite position théorique où les
deux joueurs se sont accordés sur
l'annulaire médias off et caruana et que
en fait on a déjà au niveau du
classement
les deuxièmes et troisièmes et
quatrièmes
lefort regardez ce que ça donne aussi on
avait fait des petits paris avec avec
stouff pour la place des joueurs de
mettre ton petit prague place à une
partie intéressante 1 mais il va faire
recenser un petit peu
où on en est voilà à une partie
intéressante avec une structure
déséquilibrée entre prague et ici penco
voilà et grosse réflexion pour sip n'co
pas si facile cette position et de la
paire de fou en fait il à la paire de
fou prague et il a donné
la structure en échange de cette jolie
paire de fou on va regarder comment
s'est passée dont la vente à 3
a été pas mal utilisé dans le tournoi
cette variante à 3 intéressante on avait
vu c'était vendre forest qui avait fait
une gagnée de manière assez éclatante
avec cette variante je me trompe pas et
ça souffle
ouais c'est ça oui c'est ça avec l'idée
en fait on dit vas-y donne moi ton fou
et après on voit qu'il ya des idées de
balancer tous les tous les pions et des
fois voilà c'était ça la structure qui
s'était passé aujourd'hui c'est la même
chose à son cstb 6 9 3 voilà c'est c'est
du grand classique on joue pour 4,4 si
vous voulez dans cette position là et en
échange il ya souvent ce plan là qui est
plébiscité avec baignoire pour essayer
de faire mal il ya cavaliers 1 8 k et
des six aussi un
c'est pour ça que les noirs normalement
retarde pas dans toutes les variantes
mais retarde le coût des six que c'est
tentant de le jouer pour éviter les 5
mais ça peut être aussi un bon passage
pour le cavalier pour m une triple
attaque sur ce plan c'est 4 le même
l'attaqué par transparence avec tours
s'est vite en plus c'est très
intéressant cavaliers 8 une bonne
variante j'avais j'avais joué déjà cette
variante elle et elle est super bien et
je la trouvais intéressant de sous pour
agresser les joueurs de nîmes zone
réputée solide
on fait des parties vraiment rigolote
fois six f4 one et là on est aux portes
de quelque chose avec f5 alors qu'havas
ya cinq on va donner le pion en fait et
on va commencer notre attaque on est en
grosse avance par rapport à l'attaqué on
accepte d'avoir le pion de moi no 4 5 a
été jouée grand classique des six penco
point f point f
dcb c'est pour moi on est encore dans
une certaine théorie ça me dit quelque
chose ok j'ai récupéré les cases noires
mais ici point qu il va pas les laisser
facilement après la longue date
on n'a pas joué des six atempo donc ce
n'est pas si facile
comme on va jouer avec les blancs
et si par exemple il n'y a pas de
tactique je crois pas il ya presque en
essayant attaque foule essaie de trouver
ça tient mais fera dans sur wii déjà et
c'est peut-être les petites tactiques
qui le gêne
sinon il ya dames 7 mais c'est moins
naturel visuellement
là
petites tactiques
phil est là les pièces non protégés
un cadre c'est quand même embêtant
d'être obligé jouer ou bessette et tours
ben ouais bah il n'a pas le choix il va
pas trouver mieux
donc des six a été joué 1
et si socke est donc damas 4 p 7
bien ça serait déjà un petit peu pénible
et sans doute que ça tient comme nous le
disent tous et pour l'instant on a du
mal à voir comment le fou de prague va
faire pour pour s'activer parce que
c'est le foot distinctif du coup là il
tape sur du dur
comment je vais faire stouff
jeux de couleurs avec le fou de cases
noires unique ici pour
les blancs
facile à
kopunek 4 c'est simple
ouais
sur le long terme si prague n'arrive pas
trouver quelque chose il peut être en
difficulté donc la cavale et g3 il joue
très vite donc je pense qu'il connaît la
position toof montpetit prague
voit la structure des blancs avec autant
casser ou d'ériger un pion à 3 isolé gc
3,5 à deux doublés isolé etc et j'ai
aussi un plan f4 mal placé parce que du
coup ils bloquent monde cherche en 15
mois nous avons une structure très très
très mauvaise s'ils vont en jarez va
falloir ma perte de fou et la casse des
5es sur deux choses le pion désiste
aussi arriver eh ben je peux vraiment
avoir d'aidé des belles choses mais
sinon c'est compliqué pour les blancs au
niveau de la structure vont
trouver des idées des choses assez
rapides donc là car il je crois attaque
au psg si c'est normal et là
on aura envie de faire une idée de folie
à 15,4 à shanghai ne peut pas
qu'est ce qu'il a prévu après g6
c'est tout menace d'un cran
de 5,9 on nous dira si c'est la prépa ou
pas stouff
classified
voilà donc le poulain de stouff prague
en tout cas ouverture ambitieux je pense
qu'il connaît vraiment bien la position
parce que son temps à 1h37 montre
véritablement qu'il est qu'il est
préparé par contre je maintenant à un
petit peu comme enjeu la position je
passe à 20 pid
je sais pas quand il va jouer cette
position s'avère compliqué hein c'est
pas compliqué a du mal à juger cette
audition d'allemands est tellement il ya
des problèmes de structure de partout ça
c'est concret un
g6 devrait être joué parce que oui bon
il ya on remarque adam 17 aussi qui doit
être un coût etc
mais
oui je me demande en fait comment jouer
avec les blancs parce qu'il a forcément
quelque chose
après j'ai six comment on fait quoi pour
jouer à cette position et les blancs
parce que si on trouve pas quelque chose
rapidement non mais j'ai besoin de
travailler de vous prendre fin que j'ai
pas vous promettre 5 sur 10 bon je fasse
ses bandas les membres non mais après je
pars c4 donc pas sectaire
ouais mais il faut toujours faire gaffe
en tout cas parce que tout à l'heure
pour un f5 avait tout reprend à tour
contrôlé
à cause des saints qui a toujours ce
thème là
une menace pour pas qui prend son temps
et si penco
forcément
et du coup faire un truc g6 neuville et
pas sur un donc est ce qu'on peut faire
[ __ ] un f5 la proposition
opposition de foot pro f 5
relation avec d'amd 5 après à tout
moment se trouve que je peux directement
peut-être même prononcé carte ici c'est
pas clair
et f5 et le pion c4 qui traîne à la fin
aussi comme tu le disais on enlève
sangam des sacs ou je mets mon roi
logique jeu ans
pas aimer mon
j'allais faire quoi un tour f ça tu
pouvais faire aussi peut-être pour pas
être ouais moi je suis ça paraissait
logique
un an d'un procès 6
bon je me débarrasse voix
avant
cette 4e tour d'un
tournoi eux mêmes et on regarde ça va
mieux à chanteix la course et me dit on
c'est
moi je me suis battue de ma faiblesse et
puis
on va voir sa part alors que ça a déjà
été joué
et j'ai trois
cavaliers recettes pas de blague
de blague tactique
f blague mais il peut y avoir tout prend
f5 c'est pas un coup si ridicule que ça
non plus hein
son
être prague alors qu'est ce qu'on va
voir un petit peu pour continuer le tour
des stades pour des échiquiers stouff
est ce que tu veux aller voir
on pourrait aller voir ce qu'on a vu on
n'a pas vu encore voir bonne foi grandit
on a vu aussi rapidement de tous leurs
bons rails à kingsville ça va faire
annuler dans tant de coups
franchement je suis en train avec son
20e la [ __ ] comment je tremble le
réglage sur la lgv est là ça fait une
heure qu ils savent qu'ils ont fait un
nul quoi tu as assez bizarre
et donc ouais au revoir bons pourront
pas les voir grandir youth est parti
aujourd'hui à se mettre sous la dent
stouff on sent bien la dernière ronde
sans magnus et
les gros combattants grande des lieux
sûrs à quelque chose près y aura quelque
chose et vendre forest je pense qu'ils
voulaient jouer
ainsi nom bizarre de jouer food il
pouvait jouer un des millions de normal
et lorsqu'il a eu je pense qu'il a une
idée quand même bien c'est un peu mon
neveu il veut gagner ben en fait il ya
eu 12 h au café le rapidement et
peut-être qu'ils répètent un poids un
truc et c'est d'avoir un mois je pense
que ça joue je pense à jour on aura
trois parties qui joue prague un grand
des lieux et celle là je pense
ok pas une partie qui paraît
est détonante mais le fou est pas
terrible dans cette position là alors là
il aurait rebouger sont fous sans doute
pour mettant des trois jours cavalier e
sata et d2 et du coup il n'a pas voulu
tout ça championne elle a directement
fait eux cinq
ils choisi le pion isolé lui même
et un tout petit peu bizarre ça qu'il ya
eu pas mal dé change de pièce du coup
pour aller dans cette position depuis
isolé
je trouve que c'est assez étonnant de la
part des droits
en tout cas là je n'aime pas on l'a vu
un
elle indique une position plus facile à
jouer pour les blancs un champion ni
n'est pas inquiet il veut
jouer avec son chien isolés jeudi de
sons voilà ça ne devrait devrait tenir
mais
les échanges de pièces mineurs favorise
quand même le camp
ah ouais le camp blanc forcément stouff
d'autant plus que je reste avec mon
mauvais fou aux blacks avalé un cinglant
prend peut-être f3 et après je joue
cavalier à trois cas et ses deux je fixe
angers cavaliers à 3 directement qui se
regardent
voudrais juste éviter en tout que je
peux jouer qu'à les deux mais j'ai pas
envie de me prendre un moment des cartes
info je fasse attention à ça la vende
forest il va réfléchir à son
architecture de pièces
non mais pas une position très rigolote
pour l'instant donc les parties les plus
rigolotes pour l'instant d'après canada
c'est vraiment sympa comme partie très
déséquilibrée pour l'instant ici la
position qu'on a sous les yeux ben ouais
c'est pas là la plus
belle a plus la plus funky on va dire ça
comme ça tout va et on a aussi la partie
de marc andré maori dit moi j'aimerais
bien voir un petit peu ce que ça donne
se trouvent parce que c'est la partie la
même somme est à +1 pas aujourd'hui
ouais en plus vous aujourd'hui il joue
entre le numéro un tourneur et ghazi à
l'intox et a laissé le goal enfants -
c'est
en plus la garde plus dangereux parce
que bombe a eu lieu la grille du tournoi
et puis donc où c'est intéressant je
pense que les 200 pression
qu'on va aller voir cette partie
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé on vient
d'avoir le coup ou pas
l'impression qui vient d'avoir validé
deux oui quasiment à l'instant
art
par marques ans et ça fait réfléchir
[Musique]
riga esi
pourquoi pas un contrat on se libérait
qu'il adorerait kerrigan izy fa ce
problème prend rff sur mon choix est
fait oui mais ça va passer quand
une belle boulette du suspense enfin
petit prono surtout f5
réparer ouais ouais f5 salaires logique
pour maintenir
maintenir la pression
sympa
un petit plus ici avec les noirs alors
qu'est ce qu'il a prévu sur foued 5 on
peut le jouer
lâche et c
du coup
faire
parfois f5
est ce qu'il a prévu
à un moment je sors de ce demi pétrin
j'ai toujours pas que trois envoyés à
yacine marzouki a aidé 5-1 peut-être là
pour ses 5
un tag le fou
quelque part j'ai 6
voilà ce que je jouerais un as
et blanc j'ai enfin réussi à sortir un
petit peu de lait tôt mais ça va me
coûter des tempos de développement
adverse à calais b 17 pour ces huit
peut-être pas simple quand même cette
position pour toujours pas simple
après je vois stouff arrivée et les hits
qui a essayé 5 ha et des trois bons
parce que maintenant
pour marc en
vain être un petit peu dur il va avoir
la pression contre lui c'est résister il
peut jouer pour nulle m déjà il ya une
petite pression des noirs un jeu plus
facile si tu veux se trouve à mon niveau
tel que je vois les choses et ça va
mieux il ya eu une idée que j'aime bien
pour les noirs c'est je parle d'idées un
way
f et g 4
parce que
peut jouer sur les cases blanches ouais
en fait d'après g4 et bien j'aimerais
j'aimerais pouvoir gagner en fait la
case de 4
jaloux plus ses flèches
j'essaie de repeupler l'échiquier
punaise
rapide bio froides chez aujourd'hui
c'est il faut que je fasse deux fois ça
marche
après faut voir
d'où elles viennent ses flèches
les beaux dessins je suis fier de toi
voilà j'ai galéré 1 2 ouais le pas en
faire de trop des flèches à gérer un
petit bug de temps en temps et les
flèches sont pas les enlever si
facilement que ça
pas très agréable ce histoire alors du
coup l'idée de stuff
up assez évidemment pas dans cette
position on avait dit fouet faisant un
tour ces cinq attaques le fou comme ça
sur fou g6 offert enfin 3 s'en prendre
qu'à valider cinq donc je le joue bas me
3 et stouff il veut faire ef
gf
g4 cho k1 ton roi là
l'amour est ouvert j'ai un fourneau 6
qui tient un petit peu la baraque mais
surtout quad j'aimerais manger en f3 et
après m'être un cavalier entre 4 et
profitez aussi intervenir le 4 il est
fort wayne tour en groupe qui va arriver
j'ai une belle cassent tout sur trois
est faible c'est intéressant de en fait
le terme en un combat pour la case
progresse de 4 pour le case mange
ça m'a l'air intéressant après le
pâtissier le monde pas que cela
intéresse beaucoup j'aime bien
maintenant
et on proposait autrement voilà ça c'est
une première manière de faire ce qui est
fou tu manques et b17
pour senatus et trompe pas tour ces deux
on peut pas tour c'est un seulement
les tours ce set c'est à tour c'est sa
job bien sûr
je te confions pour ses sets j'ai envie
de te laisser stouffs que j'ai droit de
laisser tour ses huit tours des 8 et ses
neuf attaques youtube
mais fait pour celui de tomber c'est tu
pourras pas bougé de cavalli et tf6 à
cause du careï 17 gratter du cavalier
français 5a va laisser ça à ce que j'ai
envie j'ai envie de te laisser tous les
pions on regarde à tour ses villas pour
métro et
ça c'est un cauchemar pour le blanc vrai
cauchemar pour les blancs parce que j'ai
en fait juste voir le développement des
blancs et des noirs
on a moins de deux pions inquiet blanc
qu'on a et b passé mais regardez le roi
regarder la tour le fouet fin c'est un
cauchemar et là on va te rend une
tactique
pratiquement
égal avec je regardais même avec eux pro
f 3 j'ai pris froid et cavaliers 4 et
revient la charge est tout fier rigole
il envoie là ils aiment bien leur
position ils réactivent tactiquement
avec une belle idée
et il donnerait encore un cavalier a eu
l'idée de récupérer en fait du
l'autre cavaliers pour venir taper la
pièce louée et encore des fous il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on investit
comme ça des fois on regarde pas
trop la dépense et faut être sûr de se
faire rembourser à la fin quand même
souffert en tout cas c'est pas passé de
bien sûr bien sûr la décennie en tout
cas tactiquement au centre ça
pas le mieux donc autorisé
jusqu'à manche premier noir tous les
jours avant que ça fait peur en tout cas
ça fait peur
on va voir comment on va entendre est un
petit peu en souffrance du coup et là
des décisions difficiles à prendre et on
va voir un peu comment il réagit déjà il
est il a repris entre il peut réfléchir
dans cette position très intéressante et
on sait que l'église est maintenant
qu'il y avait toujours été un topo ne
connaît plus la pause déjà pas mal
oui connais la pause mais connaît pas ce
coup voilà il ya donc c'est moins facile
pour lui que tout à l'heure où il
envoyait tous les coins tempo
ok alors est-ce qu'on repart dans le
vaste ouf
allez donc
mon caractère je refuse à les voir par
contre
peut-être on peut aller voir du coup à
prague est-ce qui n'ont pas d'abri n'a
en effet pas affichés mais est-ce que
c'est pas nul maintenant on fait un
gâteau en fait tu sais que visites
contre 40 scène il a il a dit en fait
bon jack bauer je crois dans la partie
se situe à la femme nue le fumage
chinois qu'ils ont eu en fait tu vas y
disait que il voulait donc il a dit dans
l'interview comment il a fait exprès de
jouer une partie longue alors qu'ils
pouvaient faire nul facilement avant
mais déjà il voulait juste jouer et
jakarta s'est battu a joint un petit peu
plus et puis enfin venu comme ça il est
un petit peu tard parce qu'il pouvait
faire du facilement mais l'idée en fait
c'est que ben ali là il veut jouer il
veut jouer et donc là je pense qu'il va
faire une facile
mais il a envie de jouer ce qu'il avait
dit contre 47
l'idée mais
il a envie de jouer aux échecs mais
c'est pas facile
cheikh moderne des fois quand l'autre à
d'essayer de bien le bloquer ben laden
des positions pas très rigolote un peu
sèche le lacie vous entraperçu
l'échiquier entre cariat qui n'évite
déjà en finale tour fou cinq pions
contours flous cinq pions avec aucun
déséquilibre c'est à dire que la
structure est symétrique donc des
l'échiquier donc c'est pas très rigolo
alors se trouve cette position
mais comme talent certain
on
veut pas dire on peut pas dire
oui il ya moins d'un mois ça a l'air un
peu ça leur souplesse aux deux meilleurs
tours ben j'aime bien pour éviter les
foules bessette je sais pas trop mais
tombe bien dans ma 5 faire attention
qu'ils ont quand même
je sais pas trop on a même droit bien
être jouée par prague c'est assez
logique aussi un de sortir ses pires s à
cette position sur le long terme s'il
fait pas la différence elle a un petit
peu inquiétante par exemple là je
verrais bien un g6 j'ai envie de jouer
tout à l'heure mais une tactique et
cavaliers f6 après
il ya eu même du dessin pouvoir
surveiller un jour là que vise à fédérer
vient bien vu souffre qu'on sait 50 cm
et 5 mai derniers le lait vis-à-vis des
fois ci c'est fou détroit ça peut
sûrement déposé probablement à ce qui
m'inquiète un peu c'est dans quelques
coups si c'est les noirs s'organise bien
qu'est ce que je fais
avec les blancs en fait
pas trop d'idées stouff
rupture jeu la paire de rois qui est un
peu bloquée loi c'était donc trois trucs
concrets pour roman il se prend
davantage ça peut être bien mais sinon
sur le long terme c'est que là c'est
clairement favorablement sur le mans et
je trouvais ça ça
je suis hyper solide et maintenant mes
cavaliers sont plus
propices à une amélioration danser
oued dans ce genre de position
d'opposition hak structure bloqués
et les fous n'arrive pas à s'exprimer
facilement
et j'ai même la seule rupture de
l'échiquier c'est le coût des cinq que
tu indiques est ou fais je le fais quand
je veux si j'ai envie de gagner
et pas facile a pour prénom dedans
rapide maintenant des six penco plus
rapide qu'au début en tout cas
c'est à dire pas rentable être le signe
de noir
après l'action décisive des tours d un
torrent et d'opéra mais ma paire de fou
auront du mal à jouer à saint germain
et on peut même imaginer le retour dans
lequel est venu recettes à un moment de
la partie d'accord après j'aurais
cependant
tour du cavalier
et partir en recettes pour un moment
donné de la partie gérer un problème
mais après quand la position sera
stabilisée là je pourrai le ramener et
faire mal et maintenant qui en
quadrillant le set sur un g6 et ce que
je peux pas tendu h 4 h 5 essais de
d'ouvrir un peu la colonie occasion en
or j'y pensais c'était même un plan que
j'avais si tu veux tout sans même songer
6 donc il a encore plus de sens avec g6
maintenant ça m'embêtait de donner cette
case aux cavaliers quoi
si tu arrives avec mon âge 4 h 5
juger si je touche à rien mais bon
cavalier angers carte et je n'arrivais
pas à trouver le coup de boutoir
supplémentaires il ya moi si on fait j
insiste vous vivez jouer h4
pour envoyer et bien mais après quand en
plus on va être à charge touchera rien
donc là je me rends à horgues cavaliers
f6
veut dire l'idée de génie si ses
protégés le pion pour pouvoir faire
cavalier f6 il ya cette grosse carte qui
clignotent franchement je sais pas tu
vois je trouve à chaque mais je vois pas
où on voit à quoi on a donné cette case
n'aime pas trop la position j'avais pas
à jouer la position de l'ange et
patronaux respecte ces horribles en fait
mais par contre un autre plan que qui
que tu sois tu vas sourire avec après
mon coup mais applaudie salle avant
le coup quel est le coût oui
la cavalière pour aller chercher des
cadres le génie trouve mon compte
facebook
j'ai compris et j'ai compris tu voulais
en venir je sais qu'il a du boulot en
fait le g4 le g4 parce qu'on regarde
bien la paire de tous les angles penser
que tu joues oui je vais leur rêve de
hockey mais je veux faire j'ai quatre
jeux phares g4 mais j'aimerais avoir une
casse mon cavalier parce que m si je
vends aux deux badges ou après et je me
dis bas âge vent a changé je quatre
cavaliers dont soit cavale et son
cavalier à charge et 4 kg 300 cavaliers
a changé cac avait des f2 et je peux
voir j'ai plus qu'à lyon les 24
l'idée c'est vrai c'est d'ouvrir mais
fou parce que j'ai la part de fou et je
vraiment réussir à trouver quelque chose
si la mefou sont ouverts en fait le
problème pour tous à nourrir ce fou ou 3
donc faudrait que tu fasses f5 derrière
je vais t'en empêcher je fais alors je
peux pas donner ma tour en un coup avec
ses 8 et tout ça mais il reviendra là
pour faire un blocus avec cavaliers f5
et de manger peut-être je peux faire h3g
quatre souffre
avec la grande yagoua verte c'est du
délire quoique ça marche c'est un peu
fou mais d'un côté ceux qui jouent pas
ils jouent pas quelque chose 1 tu vas
tous retrouvés comme tu l'as dit adams
et sept cavaliers f6 et on va menacer
des cinq on va jouer avec six cavaliers
à 5 voire mort de ces quatre on va être
ma structure elle est très très faible
de partout donc si compliqué et parce
qu'il a joué là je cueille ses sept
c'est très bizarre
ok il a joué un si penco
cas et c'est cette pourquoi où il veut
amener ces pièces
je suis
étonné du coup de
tsypko elle n'a pas voulu toucher sa
structure sans doute ont ils pouvaient
enfin bon bref
un petit peu étonnant 1 souffre de
kookaï c7
me
quand je peux retrouver goût à leur
emphatique siens 7,15 la être qu'un jour
il veut faire des cinq le coût de ce
souper
et ferrer lecavalier en aide si simple
pour différentes raisons donc j'ai six
avaient l'air vraiment sympa
bizarre pour
l'aider du vis-à-vis et que les fous
proche des 5 to b mais bref adams et 7
pour défendre pioncer sa vie après la
case aussi donc instauré dans l'aviation
des pièces
ouais bon à voir
un épisode
ce que ça ne serait pas l'heure de la
petite pub vous le savez un un pub
obligatoire toutes les heures ou fait ce
que serait pas à l'heure de notre
première pub pour une fois que j'y pense
il y est c'est ça bravo voilà lancés en
tout cas les gars rester parmi nous on
est en 6 minutes chrono et on va voir un
peu le monde ces parties de la dernière
ronde du tata steel et oui il va gagner
mais on sait déjà c'est comme scène ça
c'est sûr mais on a de bien belles
parties et particulièrement la partie
entre prague la partie de marc andré
marois gi qui joue le numéro 1 aussi
dans le challenger donc il ya quand même
des choses sympas et on revient tout de
suite après cette courte page de pub a
tout de suite des gens à tous
[Musique]
je
et
[Musique]
oh
ban
[Musique]
à
et on est de retour pour la fiesta style
et la fin du tata steel stouff 1
bientôt la fin de ton marathon de quinze
jours de stream avec trois petites
journées de repos mais en tout cas
c'était était un gros événement en
tournoi et on était sur la partie de
prague et décider si penco avec des x
none humalex
donc on est reparti et ça bouge un peu
plus rapidement la lettonie 1 qu'il est
palisson cavagnan m6 était tellement
tentant il a préféré nommer temps c'est
cette page est toujours pas la raison
pour moi on dans une position
d'amélioration de lente pour les noirs
et je vois pas ce que vient faire le
cavalier en
ans et 7 stouff j'ai
vraiment étonné de ce choix
et je viens de voir que le rugby avait
avait joué aussi entre a joué son coup à
jouer ce petit tour 8 on la position va
pas beaucoup évolué ici
savate là ça va être l'heure où sa
position 'achat' on a vu la question
d'amadeus siguiri peu guéliz et 40 16
mois en fait qu'un n'irai nulle donc
puis même sens là nulle personne trop
trop trop de vent il a un point de vue
d' avance et puis gagner aujourd'hui en
plus donc on savait déjà donc là il y
avait ça dans ma chance et c'est déjà
fini donc là on a les quatre premiers du
classement je crois que ça peut plus
trop bouger un souci j'ai pas de bêtises
et si bien qu en gagnant peut rejoindre
guy à la quatrième place bon pour les
pros classement on sait que c'est plié
et
maintenant on a les quelques jolies
parties à voir avec celle de prague on
sait car yakine visite on peut déjà vous
dire que ça va vraisemblablement airs
nul d'hier ça bouge plus du tout
où depuis tout à l'heure
ah si ça bougeait légèrement autant pour
moi ok il n'y a vraiment pas grand chose
à jouer mais c'est pas c'est pas très
rigolo et on a autrement le petit
tourniquet de jordan entre shankland il
va travailler cette position de tir
isolé
peut-être la partie qu'on n'a pas été
voir depuis un moment c'est duda
parce que duda et la petite sicilienne
contre contre grand des lieux c'est ça
deux parties elle peut bastonner parce
qu'à un moment on va peut-être voir j'ai
carthage qatari v1
pas ce que tu en penses tout mais ouais
mais en fait ça c'est des ventes si les
nouvelles donnes ans est toujours assez
intéressant et c'est plaisant regard des
postiers voiture bon c'est un jeu ouvert
c'est compliqué sont attaqués tous
installations j'aime bien
position en tout cas ça va jouer en tout
cas ça a failli que je pensais ouais là
j'ai un tout petit souci tout fabrègues
et noir donc il ya une petite menace de
fourbes et six
jeunes ou calais 17 du coup il faudrait
pas que le faux arrivants b6 et que je
puisse plus jouer pour manger sans doute
pour b 5 b 4e si les blancs attaque tout
seul ça va être
pénible
ouais pêcheurs ou des six ans c'est
pas facilement faire ou alors j'attends
que le fou viennent en b 6 pour faire
cailler 17 mai ça paraît assez logique
de faire cailler 17
cette tactique 1
mince tactiques et stratégiques
et dans ces positions là dans les grands
thèmes aussi quand on fait des cas et
des cette fausse mais fait pas se
prendre un thème accueille des 5
l'instance a l'air d'être un peu lège
avec des ide prend on prend et je
regagne le fou et n'a peur de fourche
détruit la structure donc ça c'est un
thème connu hélas à l'air d'être ok et
surtout j'ai qu'attache 4 que je vois
bien arrivé
donc par anticipation qui avait 17 est
assez logique aussi
normal ce qu'on voit là
je jouerai même un g4 h4 g5
moi j'ai l'impression que
et blanc soit un petit peu en avance
dans cette position
ouais
en
une des parties une des parties du jour
qui devrait aller assez loin et est une
belle petite baston
le quart yakine vide c'est vraiment pas
très rigolo celle-là le promets
ok mais pour l'instant parce qu'il a
joué voyons voir des faillites 500 g 4
achetés à 2,5 moi j'aime bien ce qui se
sait ce qu'il nous faut ce qu'il nous
faut et du coup cette position elle est
rigolote mais on attend un petit peu que
ça avance et ça joue assez vite un côté
côté chant clan de vente forêt c'est
maintenant
et le cavalier e 4 incisif c'est comme
ça il faut jouer ainsi quand vous avez
un pion isolé par contre
il ya plus de deux pièces mineurs on
attend à qui a aidé 2 la part de john
ford ou forest pour peut-être venir
comme ça en a et b 3 k et des cats
facile quand même de jouer très actif
après
en d4 après madame en b3 jeu matourin en
d1
et je vais travailler les faiblesses
sauf qu'elle est difficile à jouer
art
pas hyper rigolo avec les blancs mais on
a un objectif et ça fait toute la
différence
on va voir comment ça va se passer mais
mon avis ça va être un petit peu
difficile du coup mon kayak infinite
stouff m'a interdit d'aller avoir
tellement elle est soporifique ont fait
un tour rapide vous voyez ça a évolué
pas du tout et c'est
c'est pas très rigolo à regarder mais
sait-on jamais et prague et sleeping
koba on a passé pas mal de temps et on
voit que pas qu'il est sans doute un peu
plus
longtemps que ici petko dance est dans
cette position voila apres 10 md cette
cavale et c7 évidemment on a
l'impression de se remettre c'est vrai
que ça fait la bise à ce qu'il a fait
son père mais dans ce cas pourquoi il a
fait ça vraiment mais du coup maintenant
la production halal elle commence à être
intéressante pour les blancs car angers
6 ça casse et j'ai l'impression jusqu'à
vallée m6 ça tu es le comte roger des
blancs mais ici bon on doit avoir un
emploi je pense qu'il a eu peur des
dégâts valiev 5 des sacrifices éternité
ça je pense qu'il a eu peur le genre de
choses en face et spring court
mais en fait ils pouvaient par et avec
justice mais j'ai 6 il n'a pas voulu
toucher sa structure de pions que
normalement ok si vous faites j'ai ici
si vous favorisez le jeu sur 15 noirs
des blancs sauf qu'on n'avait pas trouvé
de passage
donc j'ai six cavaliers m6 marché et en
peluche que j'étais en lien et les cases
d'avant pas sur la case de quatre futurs
d'avant postes éventuellement j'écarte
aussi
donc extrêmement bizarre on ce qu'on a
vu dans cette danse est partie la
phénologie moment qu'on ait parlé dans
le challenger aussi on va on va tourner
assez vite on a moins d'échiquier dans
le a pour ce début de rallye et qui joue
pas il ya eu deux parties nulles très
très vite donc donc quasi l'âge et
auront huit en tout pas les voir si tu
veux ouais ouais 8 je les ai vus à
l'écran tout à l'heure
on se réflexion
en fait 3 8 à une forme de logique c'est
de ne pas se prendre pour ses 5 pourquoi
f5 le coup il ya toujours les menaces de
cas et des cinq sur sur trois ne peut
faire marc andré par contre
c'est faire cavalier prend 1,4 ce tout
feu
s'est calmé la position où il y avait
les prends un pion prend en fou prend et
après c'est de jouer mais bon après la
structure n est pas bonne qu'avant je
suis maman jacqueline torra sur
une croix sur mon pions
mais faut aussi ce jeu fait eux trois
près par exemple
moi la fosse commune assad peut n'être
pas sûr peut-être même fougue et cette
franchise que le rebond du dollar plus
fort d'ailleurs ouais faut aussi joreige
ab3 je pense
y avait une arme marans est souvent sur
fois aussi son se dit
pas qu'on peut laisser le pion à deux
avec la fermeture avec b3 mais déjà il
ya 5 à 4
je joue bien il vient attaquer
c est mignon mignon
pas ça dans toutes les positions mais je
peux juger une porte de sortie la manche
tout filmé passants font 1,6 il fait
plus tôt
allez
l'ags de l'échiquier qui m'a pas remis
blanc recouvre pour répondre à ma douce
comment comment le fou est bloqué en le
système ça fait celle-là ah oui tu pu
bouger organise pas j'avais fait un truc
à larache comme s'attaque
au lendemain d'une technique
alors juste pour répondre amadeus dans
la partie donc damage chômage frappe qui
part d'un parti de prague
mal placé simplement il salua florence
rejetez pas bien flou je t'ai pas saluer
beaucoup et à la dame en charge 3 je
serai mal placé au final donc
je suis pas en fait j'ai six c1 coûts
d'améliorations je pense pour les noirs
pour empêcher qu te ment lecavalier h5
tous à défendre bien le curé f5 je pense
pas que jésus se rendre à la solution
sur 15 mois parce que le foot roi du
vraiment du mal entre sur les cases
noires mais la maj 5 je pense pas
favoriser enfin tu vas plus tôt et les
noirs je pense c'est à davantage prendre
ma place et je pense qu'on pense à sur
damas a presque envie de refaire le plan
cavale de huit cavaliers f6
j'y tiens à cette case pour le cavale
aussi mélioration des pièges support
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
en fait la caisse qui va qu'est ce qui
va faire chier toujours pas avec les
blancs comment comment jouer cette pause
pas si facile et quand même
or nul d'ailleurs cette partie de joie
ne sont pas grand chose
alors après j'étais en train de rêver
d'un roi je suis calé j'ai vite
cavaliers f6
absolument faire le 15
c'est hyper bizarre chez mais chez parce
qu'il est venu faire et le cam alliance
est lorsqu on peut estimer peut-être à
un moment pour l'instant je peux plus le
faire tant que j'ai passées ici j'ai
toujours su pions là à surveiller c'est
hyper bizarre aussi je voulais faire ce
genre de choses et maintenant il ya le
problème c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'ils
en l'air donc c'est
compliqué
ceux ci ayant fait preuve 5 aïe aïe aïe
bon bah du coup
il va nous dire les cip en cause qui l'a
vu mon plan
moi je ne sais pas
le faire
autre vraiment jordan hill travail
envoie en temps réel ce joli petit film
pensait qu'il avait passé par des deux
profitant du cavalier en quatre mais il
a préféré à 3 peut-être qu'ils veulent
en bessin b5 c'est du classique avec en
fait
elle valide écarte toujours possible
mais bon qu'est ce que ça change une
fois que tu as en baisse 5 façons tu vas
arriver là on est droit je trouve que
boyet en fait peut être que tous les
coups se ressembler un petit peu avec la
même idée de venir travailler
sauf qu'en d2 tu bloques padam donc tu
peux rester un peu plus souple avec ton
cavaliers peut-être joué dam des trois
directement tour d un oiseau quelque peu
à l'écart va lécher de cavaler baisser
donc on va dire que tu as deux seront
peut-être qui m'est chère après si on a
donc oui et puis en prise en ce qu'ils
pouvaient rouler les deux il a dû se
décider pour un coût un forcément
franchement ouais moi jamais jamais
cabella 3 bat sam de plus d'options
quand même même si on va se cacher un
c'est toujours la même idée un
intéressant cette idée dans le début
long de faux de
petit révolutionnaire un grand mot mais
est pas bête en mettre du tout
envie de la partie pour invalider on le
rappelle
est changée dons concédés c'est
peut-être pas forcer non plus mais bon
il a échangé le foot 15 morts peut-être
qu'il devait jouer avec fou c est aussi
un clin d' il y en a mais voir s'il y
avait l'idée est le fond f4 de faire ces
trois b4 peut-être impossible le vent a
bien aimé voir cet artiste ouf s'en fout
des six parce que là je crois que
champlain il s'est un peu trompé quand
même passé de position de paraître dur à
jouer
il va souffrir pendant longtemps ça se
mérite une nulle à ce niveau là mais en
fait le truc c'est que j'en connais je
peux vraiment pour un résultat je pense
je crois que t'es allé dire ça se mérite
un seul
j pas penser est vrai qu'il faut que je
soutienne plus jordan la partie et moins
funky que d'habitude des habitudes
jarden il envoie tout est là le fait est
qu'on lui a proposé un une partie à deux
résultats donc il est assez content
quand même c'est gratos
non mais moi je vois bien avant le faut
la gagner ouais un peu mal au coeur mais
je le vois
le petit salon là dessus alors mais je
le vois bien un point sur le classement
tout fait ce que tu te rappelles est-ce
que tu allais mais les pronos avec toi
t'as petit à petit on
peut faire ça déjà pour profiter du
temps un peu creux de ce début de partie
ok alors donc je vais peut-être
commencer par l'obtient tout l'avant
leurs mails en ce sens yes yes et après
tu nous avais fait une petite grille
avec les trucs qu'on était d'accord
c'était pas mal ah oui j'avais pris la
photo on attendait la photo
vieja
déjà là on est d'accord
enfin on ait trouvé 40 cède m'hamed
alors qu'un sony ciel déjà on sait pas
trop m'hamed rapporte assure on avait
moi je vais marquer enfin on aime tous
les deux marqué un karl scène m'hamed
gear et web on ne sait pas si loin mais
ces quinzaines m'hamed et rapporte qui
s'était intercalé et moi je vais marquer
rapport aux 4 et toi alors attends c'est
bien parce que bien un vrai justin
verser rapporté guéri oui mais bon ça me
fait un mini sata et luis fabiano 4
nages pensaient qu'il allait revenir
ouais pas si loin
du coup on va voir donc là on n'est pas
bon donc en fait bon le truc bond de 60
devant si on est bon on ne parle que de
ça un
cadre dirigeant en bas en bas
malheureusement un bas on n'avait pas
prévu dans un truc de bois fifres et
fort score ouais c'est ça heureusement
ensuite 5e
moi j'ai vite dit
il à 6
non mais là il va passer ni c est super
haut qui joue en fait j'ai un gros coup
de bol aussi à grande des lieux ce que
j'ai mis sans faire exprès numéro 2
mais qui joue au hasard je me suis
trompé je voulais mettre grands débuts
ce dernier et prague d'ananda
et prague mananda devant et du coup en
retranscrivant et en envoyant ce tout
j'ai mis grand déluge 13e et là ils
menacent sauf à gagner la dernière
ah ouais franchement c'est possible
qu'il doit avoir
on va voir en tout cas
en tout cas donc 5e toi tu ami richard
rapport donc il est deuxième moi j'ai
mis
moi j'ai mis vie dit donc ce sera pas le
cas non plus
gagner cette position
sixième à jeu suivant
tata milouda moi j'ai mis ko naing
que à william and forest qui a si c'est
pas du tout sûr qu'on casse un quai
ligny si vous ne ferez se gagne je suis
fou de sucre encore à cause de lui qu'il
a avec ça il va passer jusqu'au bout
mais si votre forest gagne
fait nul sa zone de partage donc il faut
il faudrait que le problème c'est que
j'ai mes chances j'en crois quoi parce
que sinon il faudrait se fait nulle fois
qu'il arrive ben d'arrière excepté une
connerie l'europe de gagner
bon je veux voir grèce pourrait en tout
cas j'ai une chance avec caruana 6e
7e j'ai vu moi j'ai mis duda
duda donc là à 5 ennemi goudal qui peut
faire nul est arrivé ses ennemis même
gagné un
cha micky
7e vu d'ici
ça joue en un c'est tout est jouable
encore
après tamil 8e car yakine ben ça joue
aussi série des mortal je pense en tout
ça ouais ça on n'était pas sûr on savait
qu'ils seraient dans le ventre-mou
échantillon d'un peu détaché on avait on
avait dû le prévoir à peu près aussi
quand même ettori
magic woman forest à 8e mais bon s'ils
gagnent pas ça vous change ou un
9e le gmi et si penco
bon j'aurais du mal à le voir perdre
quand même
je pense qu'il ya pas de
calais - time ici penco aussi
dixième muse et mica yakine ce serait
mérité mais le choix du coeur avant il
perdra pas je pense quand même et toi tu
as mis 10e band soir est donc bon perdu
aussi
je pense
basdevant de forest et il lui le coiffe
au poteau barrières non mon nom de froid
pas maman
11e bat hamidou bof moi j'ai vu du beau
aussi
hélas 12 suis ami chant clan
gagnent
le double et qui le dépasse et qui s'en
vont en perdre ça me paraît beaucoup
comme et moi d'où ces méchants quand
aussi
13 cela que tu fais
un
truc c'est que grand délice gagne cinq
dernières parties que prague père
est là du coup tu es toi
parce que tu voulais plus vous voulez
mettre traque d'un nul tant est grande
mais il se passe que du boeuf du golfe
forfait le général et du coup tu vas
être bon grâce à ça sinon c'est moi qui
avais le
vol d'essai non fête
mais je comprends mais il a eu lieu à
prague il a eu à une élue un seul
gratuit en battant en battant de boeuf
mais bon lâchement relate la fia
classement vols de gol et skype qui lui
demande qu'est ce qui se passe à
karlsson médaille gagnée tout de suite
puisque son adversaire et positifs qu'on
vide dont pas deux derniers affrontent
pour quinzaine amadeus on est bien
d'accord avec toi c'est la dégringolade
pour
pour caruana en ce moment et du coup
quinzaine a gagné le tournoi dès hier et
525 qui nous donne pas le résultat du
tennis il nous dit qu'il ya un gros gros
match de tennis
entre medvedev ennahda 20 et il nous
donne pas le score aux données score
dans ce cas là dans le chat en train de
regarder le tennis apparaît logique
voilà
et
bonjour le petit pressing devant de
forest on aura mais ce que le classement
est bon en direct ça c'est pas sûr ils
font pas le départage peut-être souffle
l'occasion de me wade doit pas être beau
mais après tu peux regarder on voit pour
garder quatre ans mais le classement qui
est
qui et que tu as toi sur le sol obs non
il ya jours pas bête mais bon ça va pas
changer grand chose à y
sont
en tout cas on a en plus encore mais là
tu vois je crois que je vais je vais
enfin programme des lieux
hors tva top comme juliette star tu vas
tu vas y être point un bon compte encore
j'ai l'impression danse tata steel
l'armée arrête les franchement fouquin
le mec qui parient sur le fait grandiose
va être d'arriver avant dernier il
prague il va arriver dernier et il se
passe que d'une poche
qui botte tournoi et du coup tu gagnes
sur la grand-place quoi
ils sont moins les gars amadeus et 2 525
donné les scores en même temps est très
très chaud au tennis et plus chaud que
la partie devant le port est à voilà
l'idée de vente forest n'a pas mis son
cas est en d2 comme ça il se dit déjà
mon cas et en c2 il est très souple il
peut arriver en q3 bekkat et la gagne un
tempo sur la sur la dame il propose un
échange de dame un peu malhonnête pour
travailler les ressert c'est la
technique de l'anti jeu quand on a un
pion de plus voilà il est considèrent
eux il a une structure de plus donc il
veut aller en finale
en fait dans ces conditions le plan
destin qui les faibles simple on est
isolé donc du coup la rixe qu'il faut
bloquer le pion vous avez et ensuite les
noirs pour vraiment enfin quand on
jouait avec un pion les élèves faut
jouer actifs et l'idée c'est que plus on
échange de pièces - les noirs peuvent
des actifs et du coup on fait plus les
pièces sont échangé plus que tu en d5 et
bien il va trouver faible et du coup
dans le d4 c'est un très bon coup on
peut imaginer aussi des découpes tard
comme tour à dr et cavaliers 3 pourrait
céder attaquer le segment des 5 et ben
en fait les bleues ont sondé la très
très bien conférence est 1 wen en
roulant solution oui on indique en plus
donc ça fait que conforter
façon stouff ne se trompe jamais je te
le dis n'importe où sache à part au
niveau des paris vous fait quelques
secondes et quelques petites erreurs
il avait été par
le gros du tournoi sur sur prague avait
essayé d'être un petit peu de joueurs en
choisissant vent de forest mais il est
quand même plus stable encore
choisissant le bon choix sont gagnants
de son concours j'ai vraiment oublié
je réponds j'avais moi aussi j'ai moi
aussi avec mais en fait tu imagines tu
joues du boeuf non cela t'est cagoulés
quoi ce tournoi parce que c'était comme
notre fil rouge le pari principal et
après on s'est fait plein de petits
paris dont les petites victoires
indépendante ça c'était c'est assez
marrant aussi ça nous permet tous les
jours de vibrer et on va pouvoir aller
voir un peu prague on est resté sur sept
ce travail-là du pur isolé pour vous
c'est quand même intéressant on parle
souvent la structure du point isolé
et il décide d'aller dans la finale et
de la tenir
va être dur comme cette finale ce qu'on
préfère nous y avait là pour des cons le
tour le tour pour travailler autour du
pied isolé mais si les cavaliers
s'échange on en sera très dur
ok donc je j'annonce j'annonce grain à
moudre aux il va travailler en tout cas
est ce que est ce que tu apparais un
petit surf sur le gardon encore est à
non non non non j'en gagne déjà
je me refaire je vous rappel c'est bien
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien préfère ça à
les petits ils parient spectacle non
vous étiez en train de commenter avec
ses amis je n'ai pas assez entre deux
cours et je voyais regarder la position
de rapports qu'ont caruana et
franchement elle est chez je t'ai dit
mais tu m'as dit ah non pas du tout moi
dans une position qu'on aurait
facilement gagné et ça ça va être le cas
où paris est paris
et à lyon on va vous emmener vers la
petite partie de de prague est ce qu
elle évolue je sais pas ce qui fait avec
ses cavaliers et veut me faire rager
assez saccadée chez lui et l'a fini par
juger 6 et moins une russe mais les
bénéfices incroyables deux
semaines maintenant c'est cette cavale
et b6 sémalens as tu vois des gens qui
arrêtent un de comprendre son idée
ils veulent juste pour jouer sa tour
peut-être pour protéger sa tour qu'un
essai 7 et après calais b 6 à casser le
pion aux handicaps
et peut-être après la messe est aussi
essayer d'aller bourrer le plan ségara
les coûts de ces pièces et lecavalier
après une qui rappelle son rôle après on
pense à cette voir revenir 8 6 7 et son
idée j'ai
un contrat je fus f2 qui seront la
colonne et peut-être de laisser passer
le fou en vendée en h4
mais j'étais avant que j'incarne mal à
trouver un plan pour le barça racing
tout à l'heure
ouais ouais ça si je pouvais enlevé le
tueur c3 quoi
toi tu sais pas où et quand je passe mon
tour je te prendre ce prof te le donne
on veut enlever son propre pions je
rappelle qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire
ça aux échecs mais c'est très
pédagogique il veut vous montrer que là
on exploitera les cases noires comme y'a
pas de foot 15 noir en face à vue
l'affaiblissement qui vient d'être créé
là on en profiterait est ce qu'on a dit
n'y a pas de passage qu'on se fout réel
sifwat cardell c'est dingue j'ai du mal
à savoir comment jouer en voie de la
jauge aime bien lundi que les blancs
sont mieux moi j'ai du mal à trouver un
plan alors peut-être le retour de
j'écarte un moment ça ça et j'ai carte
voilà du coup que je suis la casse des 5
1 voilà qui avaient des f1 ou trois
dessins coloriages prend pour le cavale
c'est pas mal je pense tout fin ce
serait pas déjà de linge des français 4
le 2e point 1-1 des cinq il ya toujours
la pression sur sur f5 et aussi de
vendre rupture gkp regarder les doigts
enfin
enfin proposé
uni
enfin je suis content franchement ça
fait une blague on faisait les rênes
micro c'est parce qu'on doit faire donc
à mon améliore les pièces avec des
blancs mais normalement il aurait dû
mieux faire avec les noirs et ça aurait
été beaucoup plus difficile si j'avais
le cavalier un f6
et cava lieu qu'à des cavaliers cats
auraient été beaucoup plus sympa
la donner davantage penser cipango bien
peu de fatigue des joueurs malgré le
fait qu'ils soient hyper fort
bah évidemment
lymphatique c'est normal
iachini 10 à jour que moi je sors la
bonne victoire devant des lieux cela et
merci amadeus un
tennis en direct live avec deux
commentateurs dans le chat
et on n'a
toujours rien chez carrier à quinéville
du mont la purge donc on peut aller voir
la partie rigolote entre gandré youth et
duda l'aï regardé 8
hockey et b6 sajoo mais j'ai envie
d'aller voir cette partie parce que il a
laissé le souvenir en b6 étonnant wen
après quelques jours jocaille et 7 oui
parce qu'on avait dit donc c'est pas si
grave
qu'elle ait 17 vous faites le manach
fois à cette dame s'est certes et
attention de pas se faire là enfermé
avec b61 le clasico perdre de temps d'un
toit cette ville il faut revenir à une
cave à être confiant des cadres - ca et
sur sept est donc là je pense qu il faut
commencer à envoyer les pions donc g4 en
plus cela vous voyez il ya un thème qui
est très important dans les céciliennes
est en fait h6 vaut bien sûr c'est bien
sûr c'est c'est un coup il faire
intéressant dans la position où wyclef
en jouant à 6 pour revenir en arrière et
autres h61 kevin bien sûr les blancs dû
perdre du temps à reculer les fous il ya
là je souhaite 4 et après plus tard il a
joué il a mille fois aux 3es est en fait
qu il apprécie quand même pas mal de
temps avec
avec son fou pour revenir vers une
position stable et au final au final
h6 ça fait gagner du temps aux blancs
ça fait perdre du temps au noir
[Rires]
compris le thème du loup mais du coup du
coup les noirs gagne du temps grâce h si
les blancs doivent donc du coup première
chose mais le problème d'âge 6 c'est
plus tard il y aura une rupture angers 5
et le et de problèmes aussi la rupture
avec les 5 parce que c'est pas tout ça
tu peux avancer jusqu'à g4 mais là il ya
le g4 en fait
le lit d un don pour vous la faire
simple après j'ai 4 si je pouvais
rejouer je ferais je ferais h4 et si je
peux encore rejoué eh ben je ferais
gesac est en fait l'idée c'est que
j'attaque cavale et donc je dit casse
toi + moi je veux de maths et je
voudrais à clonage la sueur hph prend
ben là comme alors je volais les tours
vont rentrer première chose et deuxième
chose importante aussi qui peut arriver
derrière si j'ai 6 ans fait et j'ai 6,5
ou hyper important parce que du coup je
vais déstabiliser le point fct le pion
au 6 qui défendent enfin qu'ils
défendent sur casse blanche et le roi
noir est pas encore au centre et why
aussi j'ai un fou en b3 qui est très
content de venir ici
enfin tu as quelqu'un réussisse et après
ashkan g5 et ben ya un lien réel pain
sur le plan réussisse et
et du coup il faut commencer à voir
comment on va se défendre contre
contre contre st il ya une supposition
kevin doit connaître tout aussi avec
très souvent dans des tentes dans dés
l'âge d'or par exemple le fou en f1
et
granger en dessous ouais quand j'ai un
fou en f1 eh ben je peux pas encore
faire hkd g5 parce que sur g5y haha je
prends h prend et comme j'ai un fou et
ben en f1 et ben may tout rachat n'est
pas défendu donc ce kit ocapri hp hp y
aurait pour un chant et la tourelle est
perdu et du coup j'avais vu un plan une
fois ça remonte à longtemps quand je
travaillais à un tout petit peu des
échecs j'avais vu un implant sympa avec
h4 pour le blanc est fou h3 avec la même
idée en fait et on est tu vas jouer tu
vas jouer j'ai cinq prises prison de un
bloc la colonne âge donc il ya plutôt
feront tour et après j'ai si ce qui va
arriver et le club va du parti affirmant
j'ai eu 6 et là tu casse tout carte
blanche c'est hyper intéressant pour
ceux qui jouent position avec les blancs
et qui aimeraient avoir des idées là je
pense que vous êtes amené pas mal
d'idées 1dans
le banc le plan des blancs et si elle
ouvert mon peut continuer voilà le but
c'est un rang d'ouvrir et puis même cela
même si dans le plan et je perds un pion
des x et bats la boule sont tellement
ouvert que c'est pas grave on joue
vraiment l'initiative en jeu pour
attaquer une nette préférence pour les
blancs ici mais
c'est pas du goût de l'ordi on voit que
c'est illégal et 17 alors seul coup pour
les noirs pour faire quelque chose parce
que je sais pas quoi faire en fait même
pas je à oued petit rien et on pensait
qu'on pouvait pas lui et moi non plus je
sais bon savoir rendez vous ça c'est bon
alors on voyait pas encore gagné le moi
j'ai commandé le plus
bas à scratcher cavale et 17 je vois
jusqu'où aux trois étoiles entre 6 et 5
de mater comme un chien ah oui c'est à
dire pour moi je vous passe un méchant
que je m'affaire collet quoi
[Musique]
d'un petit rock savamment loin mais j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
j'ai capté généralement généralement
c'est les blancs qui attendent une oie
robe blanche énervé 3 c'est un fait
grave ont quand même
dire ce qui est marrant c'est une
avancée les blancs qui attendent du
maroc pour faire j'ai quatre oui et là
il ya eu ces quatre piquionne en fait ce
que ce que j'ai dit avant plus tout à
l'heure contre sont en train de faire
ton explication après j'ai oublié de le
dire mais je vais le dire quand même
j'avais dire les noirs ne peuvent par ok
parce qu'ils ont avancé leur point de
percer et il ya du coup tout le temps h4
g5 voilà non mais en vrai là je pense
que ça va être très très dur pour nous
dérange de partir
parce que
l'attak voyez la tacc mois en fait elle
sera opposée pour m c'est un peu la
course à la taille et à l'ale dames on a
du mal à imaginer la taille de noir pour
l'instant être cavaliers 7 donc la live
wave 4 roulement attrait pour les blancs
il va ya voir cavaler 17 et après b 5
alors que genre fou
fou 3 et b5 par exemple et on pense que
c'est comme ça que tu vas jouer norbert
je vois la courbe qui abat sans baisser
il se passe quoi sur cinq
oui mais juste
avait souhaité qu est-ce qui dira le
passage 4
je sais pas j'ai pas mis leur dis donc
je ne sais pas où l'as khroub à bel air
2 2
si vous lui envoyez un g5 h 4 dans
l'autre sens
je sens que prisa
et salue fatou salut vernon à mes amours
merci beaucoup à tous
si tu savais
apparemment donc l' acharnement de
souffle j'ai vérifié leur dit du courage
et un mais je comprends pas moi j'ai
envie de jouer h 4 à tout rachat il veut
juste en direct ok bah voyons est un one
note pascal sala faudrait faire avec les
nuages 4k et 17 on n'a pas envie de
donner notre fou en faut trois ou fou d
4d de existe des quatre c'est pas bête
d'ailleurs là les deux sont bien
ce que je peux je veux j'ai cinq ans
même si vous voulez un pas de souci
là-dessus donc vous arriviez le pion et
dans les colonnes lâché et
je vais faire g5 gysi by g5 à chaque
ouais mais je vois pas trop comment je
fais maintenant g6 c'est d'abord à vite
je vais prendre le cas le fauve et trois
blessés cinq rapide tu auvergne et tu
perds encore des planchers g5 tout ça
comme
ça arrive trop vite en voyage j'aime pas
du tout mais alors pas du tout du tout
les noirs réussir donne pas cher de la
peau de
2,5 c'est la case dessin enfin je ne
vois pas comment on joue
est ce qu'il trouve l'ordinateur dans
cette position et j'essaie
de jouer 5 qui avait laissé cinq
six mois ces machins ouais mais bon je
sais trouver des trucs concrets
peut-être qu'à l'aller 2-5
je n'arrive pas c'est vraiment dur et
pourtant c'est des coucous d'écologique
dans votre assiette pouvoir vous voyez
on a envie de jouer j'ai ça qu on ouvre
tout et on a aussi j'ai si le thème
donné parce tout à l'heure
il faut absolument dégommer le four b3
sans doute mais qu'a laissé 5
ouais c'est là
c'est ça la l'astuce c'est de virer le
four b3 d'échiquier et si je pousse et 5
bon là je le temps de jouer à chaque
sans doute
sur les changes et 6 c 28 mai mais en
mieux être et failli le faire dans le
sens inverse
je peux même jouer sur lui si tu veux te
flinguer prend b3 et b5
ouais différents donc on arrive à
défendre maintenant qu'on a eu
du coup tours j'ai un salaire plus
concret mais tour grc pour m'essayer bon
j'ai pas regardé après un mec à es17
maintenant fou 3 pour passer g5
ont cassé 5 avec la même idée
ah oui maintenant je vois rejet si dans
de bonnes conditions
c'est pour ça te pousse et là c'est dur
à trouver quand même
maintenant sur cavaliers prend b3 pour
éviter les g6
je vais pas ouvrir dans sa chambre
d'hôtel mais il ya quand même g6 et
l'aef ranger il ya tour pranger qui
gagne si vous poussez mais surtout ce
qui importe c'est ça ben jaffar d'alger
deux hommes h3 alors que dans l'autre
position j'ai un pion h4 qui m'empêchent
un peu de chair ce plan mais nous aussi
ancien
donges un mois il ya eu soufflante de
l'ordi un pur là on a vérifié pourquoi
notre h4 n'était pas bon c'est à trouver
nous-mêmes mais c'est pas évident je
vais tour alger 1 parce que la tour
paraît bien placé sur la colonne donc il
peut trouver dans des lieux où saint
joryens une question audio return dans
le chat qui demande si on va jouer à 4 à
5 avec les blancs
pour enterrer les dames ben moi je suis
pas d'accord en fait
parce qu'en fait c'est toujours à 4
bon d'être déjà s'est recomposé tonton
jeu il est clairement il est ton jeu
clairement aller droit tu attaques à
partager la convention il voulait aller
vite pour attaquer après je pense
mais ouais mais revêt superbug moi c'est
tout
d'abord dû cavaler 17 en fait voilà ces
cas et ton foot 15 mars ne peut pas le
donner et trois importants ici toi je
voulais de manger manger gb 5 derrière
un genre food et 8e des loges tu parles
le b52 ouvrirait ton roi il est ouvert
en fait et une fois que tu bouges kung
fu bâche v5 direct et en fait tu as joué
à 4 donc déjà maintenant l'école bonsoir
ligne nous permet d
avancer vraiment percé du coup en
voulant contrôler la position tu avances
le point de percer et du coup à cause
d'eux
à cause de cela les noirs gagne des
tempos d'attac enfin je pense tu as
voulu freiner l'adversaire et au final
le cac et 17 qui tape temps fou ben on
te fait mal et c'est le l'effet inverse
de celui recherché je pense nous dire ça
c'est bien clair général n'ont pu
normalement tu joues tu joues jamais sur
le côté où tu es faible et basse et
recomposées donc chacun en fait attaques
de son côté donc tu veux pas trop jouer
les pions de tonghua dans cette
position-là attend que l'adversaire
avance parce que dès que tu bouges un
pion et ben tu crées une rupture en fait
pour l'adversaire
ouais en fait tuer ou et a manqué d'un
tempo à la mise si tu avais joué à cinq
ça peut exister mais il y aurait eu des
huit quand même des foules mais elle
existe est
extrêmement compliqué de faire ce que tu
as voulu essayer mais c'est vraiment
équilibristes peut pas toucher aux pions
devant son propre droit
ça existe quand même quand on arrive à
faire un blocus total là c'était pas un
blocus puisque la rb5 voilà
alors le point n'est pas tout jeune le
point de percer ici ceux en fait la
percée aux échecs c'est quand les pions
rentrons contact simplement et du coup
c'est ce qui va me permettre d'ouvrir
les colonnes amadeus là c'est très
important du coup là les noirs ils ont
avancé le point de percer parce que
imaginons on pioche rachète pour percer
je fais h4 g5 à chaque homme chef cette
flèche pas qu'ils savent rien j'ai ici
ça me prend vraiment beaucoup de temps
ça prend cinq coups alors que maintenant
dans la position que l'on a vu
d'ailleurs way grand des lieux si c'est
tromper comme nous ouf tu vois on n'est
pas si bête il a joué h4 à tromper c'est
normal mais il n'a pas trouvé tour g1
qui était super fort
et beau un sésame en oblique de jouer
aussi de jouer besoin 4 pour finir
l'explication amadeus maintenant tu vois
je en jouant h4 g4 le point de percer
temps rapproché je peux remettre les
pieds en contactant jean jé sac en trois
coups au lieu de cinq là c'est pareil
avec le coup qui aurait été proposé par
licorne situera 4 dès que je fais b5
maintenant ça rentre en contact et ça en
cas d'ouverture mais c'est ce qui est
indiqué par le couvent et 5 passes assez
ouvert beaucoup vite que si les blancs
ne touche à rien ici apparaît il faut
que je fasse b5 bi 4 à 5 à 4 5 coups au
moins encore même plus donc voilà ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important elle est assez pédagogique un
set cette partie pédagogique dans le
sens là on étudie les recomposer c'est
vraiment un exemple qui est parfait pour
étudier les recomposer son cas et décès
de logique duda il veut pas de la percée
g5 il a prévu à ce qu'on a dit avec
l'achat qu'il a tout trouvé je pense à
vue avant
peut-être la stout j'ai une idée quand
même je voulais proposer soit à l'heure
j'ai oublié je fais j'ai 5 ouais j'y
pense un gymnase et aussi bien en piste
ce parcours où
mais je souffre où il est
en fait c'est un peu comme le choc et
toi t'es genre tu as tout le monde le 5
échecs genre par exemple l'espace et 100
m 4 donc du coup peut-être que pour on
va voir angers 5 je veux pas de laisser
le temps ok alors genre cavale et b6
dimpre en bois tubize alors que lui je
bouffe parce que voilà voilà j'ai pas de
point intermédiaire prise prij regardant
j'ai pas dommage on jouerait pas moins
f4 battu ferrero et donc le double
je bouffe tout change tout
notre hacker roye b un rouge
et là je fais j'en refais 9,6 et je me
dis que mon fou bas et qu'un des cases
est-ce que tout va se faire mal très bas
quand la jauge indique que sans doute ça
doit pas être loin d'être vrai j'aime
beaucoup qui me fait plaise lacets
d'alger un homme g1 damageux de faire
tourner 8 et
g 6 je veux faire un truc à base de g6
mais j'ai quand même le fou qui tape là
et je pense que ça va être la clé pour
gagner
parce que même dame gillot ce qui est
marrant c'est de changer ce système
peut-être tu crois aussi sans vrai ça
y'a bien en fait c'est pour ça que je
proposais tour 8 d'abord et g6 après
est le seul ordre valable je pense
parce que vous savez quand on a un pur
en fait quand on a un foutu enquêteurs
comme ça
généralement fait quand j'ai un putsch
en ghetto avec la fougueuse noir bat
normalement il n'y a aucun aucun
et ça devient quoi mais j'ai quand même
du monde donc je vais aller chercher
ce que la g6 du coup c'est chaud on vous
prend prise d'un prend sous la dent
bicis ruitz d'abord de mon café
à 8 d'abord c'était le coup j'ai regardé
en quoi et damages de g6 à machete voix
fuite et il tient avec son fiancé toast
ouf
on a vu que j'ai aussi un coup de tours
ici qui serait peut-être pertinent
plutôt que d'envoyer madame qui est
quand même peut-être plus facile à
recycler que les tours donc un tour âge
quelque part
pour un jeu triple je tripe donc h3
finalement peut-être ça et ça et ça
avoir moi je fais et si ce geste
historique par ailleurs et je me dois à
présent en triplant sa va être dur pour
moi de défendre
et jesse cepap en tête il faut autre
chose que j'ai 6 7 5 générique alors
peut-être peut-être regarde regarde je
prends un blanc
je vous parle des six jeux tour f 2,8
et en fait quand ils jouent tour à tour
à charge sur wii fit mais je te du jeu
mais le roi en recettes et vas-y
je déménage souvent recettes avec vous
quasiment il peut être il peut être pas
mal hein et encore le coût de la carte
nouvelles souvent fait j'ai construit
donc là c'est là celle-là c'est pas la
cabane à ceux là ce petit muret la whey
le petit mur elle souffre
j'en ai marre c'était pendant le dans le
référentiel sera comment voulez que je
vous renvoie de référence et je crois on
va envoyer les mails là parce que ça va
plus ça eu tout à la cabane et le petit
muret c'est quand même un cd et chaque
concept
amadeus s'il fait tout rachat fin vas-y
attentes autour des achats eh ben mon
plan c'est royal fuite et je tenais
j'avoue m'être président rien à
tranquille le coût de la cabane une
nouvelle fois
bon alors comment est le cache et je me
cache je pense qu'on fasse le jeu pas
facile de dézinguer cette position tu
veux
je fais pas capable de stuff je n'ai pas
trouvé à trouver pas trouvé donc la
recycle du cavalier autrement peut-être
pour ramener du monde à la fête
je peux jouer un coup comme cavalier de
n'est pas prévue au programme mais bon
et là je fous des quelques risées 5 en
fait ouais
enfin c'est également là on a joué tous
les coups de grands des lieux mais
c'était moyen on avait vu qu'on a mis on
a vu qu'on avait saccagé la jauge donc
on a été voir
ainsi que l'ordi nous a proposé et duda
il avait tout calculé on voit qu'il a
joué à une vitesse comme c'était une
évidence connais bien ces petites m.lamy
duda et ça va assurer sa place un
grandiose l'impression maintenant bah
franchement en vrai c'est ouf parce que
j'ai 4 petit rock avec en héros jouets
si c'est vrai que relief 6 franchement
moi je mon parti je vous dis mais qui
prêtent m'en fout quoi freiner mais en
fait vous bénéficiez peur voilà bien
tout ça
mais ça fait trop peur ouais mais lui en
plus il a fait assez rapidement tu vois
oui et ça tu vois la force du joueur
basique pour lui et là maintenant un
grand delius ça va être une toute autre
partie
était favori et plus dans cette poule en
rogne échelons rock ouais après je
pourrais je pourrais écrire un bouquin
sur d'être
sais pas peut-être et c'est intéressant
et s'étend de d'abris
d'abri à larache justement voyez pas ce
que c'est dans les positions aiguë est
tout un art 1 et on le voit chez les
joueurs de haut niveau le sdf souples
sdf
sans abri salut guillot labrit tu fais
l'astuce du construite à cabannes qui
contribuerait us aid
je crois que je craque un petit peu on
entend de tombwa dégâts désolé non mais
l'exemple et c'est de la folie je trouve
l'exemple qu'on vient de voir
honnêtement c'était dur mais normalement
on a voulu garder sorte point de percer
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
duda il a quand même pas vu quelque
chose je pense se trouve tu vois il
n'avait pas vu le coup proposé par
l'ordinateur et ça c'est vraiment un
coup incroyable
l'idée tour g1 pour ouvrir avec g5 un g6
en fait là il faut vraiment tu seras
sauvé la cclat et du coup on a effectué
17 et l'idée c'était fou et 3 comme ça
en fait j'ai 5 il n'y a pas le temps
un temps de parer la différence on a
bien montré on remontre un mec avaler
c'est cinglant je faisais ça qui me
prend b3 comme dans l'autre variante et
il ya une nette différence est que ma
tour et posters angers 1 donc sur le h1
qui défend tous dans l'autre scénario et
on va bientôt faire g6 là on peut faire
justice lui-même et c'est très très fort
et si ce n'est pas possible on voit que
l'option achat qui est perdue comme on
l'a montré ici est franchie on n'en
parle même pas cela tout revient à
angers 6 a fait hyper mal
as tu es jolie un ouais hélas on est
dans l'autre scénario beaucoup plus
conventionnel puisque le coup difficile
ici c'était étaient tour à gien qui
était qui était difficile à trouver pour
pour nous et nous aussi avec stouff
directement dans cette position on avait
envie d'envoyer h4 et on avait dit
d'ailleurs cette position elle était
sûrement gagnante pour les halls et
blanc et en fait on a vu que la jauge
indiqué que ce n'était pas pas si facile
et 17 et on a fait exactement comme
comme grand des lieux s'est pas rendu
compte que cas et c'est ça qui allait
nous embêter est d'ailleurs souvent mais
on n'a pas dit on à pas on a cherché on
n'a pas trouvé qu est ce qu il fallait
jouer donc c'était bien g5 1 on a dit
danse est dans cette position et on n'a
pas réussi à prouver le bâtiment juste
besoin d'eux l'ordinateur dans cette
position on n'a pas réussi à gagner j'ai
cinq cavaliers pro b 6
salut jadis un grand b 6 on s'amusait
avec cette position là avec alex trouve
donc inchangé si ce qu'on voulait jouer
sur h projet h pranger angers
ab1 on arrivait dans cette position fois
ci on n'a pas réussi à prouver le gain
le garden jeunes s'étaient opposées
alors qu'on est d'alger on a dit en fait
effectivement apparemment on peut jouer
avec quatre absents qui est comme ça le
redis j'ai mal j'ai tout le temps voilà
on fait de passion ici on n'est pas
gagnant enfin on est gagnant on est
mieux long terme parce qu'on a une
attaque il faut encore aller chercher
pour amadeus la percée là c'est une
autre et plus ça sera ouvert devant
droit plus sera facile d'y accéder
ces bons jadis celle d'amis il me fait
trop plaisir à chaque fois que je vous
écoute après j'éclate mon cousin aux
échecs et au ps
ça s'est très très bien c'est très très
bien et c'était marrant de le dire comme
ça
au cousin mais le cousin il faut parce
que tu vas lui donner ton secret de nous
écouter avec quoi il faut partager a
jadis un way
d'émulation ouais ça fait toujours
plaisir ah oui de bananes son cousin aux
échecs
alors je pense qu'il est un gage de
secret pour lui ce qui serait un malin
mais mais pas très sport
toujours un plaisir de
battre la famille un petit jeu aime bien
bon moi c'était vraiment hyper
intéressant là on a passé un long moment
et on en a oublié un peu les autres
partis
l'historien chercher car yakine
alors que ça n'a pas changé non plus il
ya eu et le cavalier ou trois peut-être
qu'on pourrait aller voir rendre forêt
si sébastien petit coup des chevaux
par yan tu sais car
nous
pensions vide ici commence à toucher ses
pions la perdre cette position moi je
pense pas alors
du coup
on va aller voir
le petit chaperon rouge le dernier
yahoo comme ça
alors
ça c'est quoi
la vie de voir son copain tu as envie
d'aller voir son copain marquants on va
on y va tous les soirs on n'ira pas là
c'est parce qu'il ya un gros truc dans
cette partie dans cette position après
calais des quartiers du fou 17
et c4 est arrivé pour gagner le pion
directement et un peu plus le défendre
deux pions
[Musique]
ou sait si c'était sans doute une finale
des gravats à venir est par exemple
quatre ans puis on prend puis on prend
des cinq n'a pas voulu de cela
avec une majorité elle dame est un pion
toujours faible laférois f8 hkd de
contrôle
voit ses huit jeux oblige à prendre ou
pas non je m'oblige pas à embaucher tour
si c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchit
j'espère qu'il s'est pas trompé vent de
forest parce que il a voulu regagner il
a voulu gagner très vite le pur isolé
c'est un peu compliqué on le voit et des
nazis et des cavaliers des deux qui
peuvent arriver j'espère que c'est pas
trop dynamique ce qu'il a fait
et chauvin savoir s'il opte alors si tu
prends des cinq cas des deux fois deux
scoreurs problème là car je pense
notre quatre lots touron 1,8 après
d'aussi h4 mais on serait enfin c'est
pas tout à fait ce qu'on voulait ça
vraiment compliqué à mort
ah c'est pas sympa fatou parce que j'ai
pensé à la plus précédentes et je crois
que tu ne t'es pas là
du coup il a tout quitté
j'avoue j'ai en plus gelé je lui ai
d'ailleurs pour une fois que j'y pense
et du coup les couches super quoi je
suis vert fatou c'est pas gentil
sud les efforts voilà je fais et ça paye
pas sa paye pas sa lune et
surtout je trouve parce que il a fait
beaucoup beaucoup de de stream et moi
chaque week-end et les semaines sont
bien remplies mais on est hyper content
à chaque fois de commenter avec stouff
masse et des baux et chaque que l'on
voit et puis on a titre perso je n'avais
pas beaucoup fait les commentaires je
l'avais fait un petit peu
quelques commentaires mais là je le
commence à le faire plus régulièrement
et c'est hyper agréable à titre perso
bas de commenter ces parties de champion
de voir les erreurs de voir les
préparations théorique de voir les
grosses parties de carl scène bon
c'était super on s'amuse bien avec
souffre à confronter nos idées
du coup c'est plutôt 70 marrant et puis
bon en plus je gagne plein de soda
chaque fois donc ça me fait trop plaisir
quoi
sur ce est ce que on envoie ennahda qui
prend le quatrième mort aux manques
amadeus et là j'espère que tu as écouté
sur le point de percer aussi amadeus
parce que si tu t'es trop distrait par
le tennis tu arriveras pas gagné les
recomposer c'est quand même dommage
allez on part en plus du coût fixe et
ont même rappelé à presque marquant
j'avais promis qu'on avoir marre quand
on
jette un coup d'oeil regarder tout petit
coup d'oeil s était le pronom plus je
crois
donc voilà et là on va lancer la pub la
pub la pub warnault j'ai pas envie de
faire faire un bon départ à nous parce
qu'il est largement meilleur c'est le
meilleur pour la pub arnaud voilà
donc aller on envoie la pub et dans six
minutes exactement
nous sommes là voilà allez a tout de
suite a tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
la pomme
[Applaudissements]
à tous on est de retour avec vous et on
voit que vendent forest est en train de
techni fier chant clan puisqu'il a un
bon piont de plus quand même je touche
je pense que ce qui s'est passé quoi du
coup sûr cédé 5 parce qu'on avait dix
cavaliers d'un ouais en fait il a il a
joint un petit peu bizarrement
visiblement et jouer un peu timide je
pense qu'ils pensent tenir ma position
et on avait trouvé ce cas et des deux
rigolos il a préféré faire cailler des
six et ils pensent tenir cette pause
mais c'est vrai que cavaillé d2 on
n'avait pas trouvé le coup si facile
puisque pour éliminer le fou c'est
intéressant en cas de faux oeufs 2 on
avait deux coups et tours 4 et on avait
des chances avec ce cas et d2 après
qu'elle ait décimé en soumission il peut
entretenir cette cette pause il me
semble difficile au delà du pion c'est
qu'il ya des idées de de s'étendre à
l'ale allait droit dans ça paraît quand
même être un bon plus blanc il a joué
tour des saab ont plus notamment quand
tu vois quand tu vois le cavalier en d4
contre aucun mât cassé deux dents très
de la cour et le tour des cinq qui est
quand même bien défendus par le forez 3
donc on se demande quand même ok le noir
sont solides et on essaie de défendre
comme ça car pour moi mais ils n'ont pas
de jeu quoi genre même pour récupérer un
pion pour attaquer une pièce compliqué
en retour ces cinq ça vous inscrire pour
ces cas ça me casse les c pas d'entrer
sur la colonne de rein cavale et c4 et
cavaliers 5 essayer de main d'oeuvre est
un peu et c'est de toi pas comme comme
magnus hier dans l'est des cavaliers c42
est sûr b3 maintenant jeunes cavaliers
par exemple mais même comme ça casse et
3 je suis pas chaud derrière mon jeu
mais non mais bonne forest qui est bien
parti pour en faire une s à sa partie
est un petit saut ben
issa ben ouais là c'est mérité
et cardiaques
contre contre-visite est-ce qu'il va pas
finir par lui collait déjà beaucoup plus
intéressant tout à l'heure ça y
ressemblait
on voit des petites des petites choses
arriver
et pourrait se la faire coller un
engagement
c'est beaucoup moins clair il n'ya
qu'une petite partie de prêts qu'ils
ouais il ya une autre ils ont une
position agréable quand même
bien plus de pression avec le plateau de
pions des noirs notamment aussi le
[Musique]
deux fois ci ce qu'est cloud etc mais je
pense pas je vois pas vraiment à
blois problème c'est que visite il doit
quand même en travers
sa partie d'hier si ça commence à mal se
passer il peut se retrouver en
difficulté
noah est petit mais
j'ai quand même du mal à le voir perdre
si la même par exemple on va peut-être
pas en fait mais bon c'est qatar tout
trop forcer les choses comme ces quatre
pour prendre est tombé de il y aura 4 4
on m'a gardé trop fort trop chaud
[Musique]
mais dans leur année le roi eu cinq
amendes et les peut-être joué cinq ça
peut être une bonne idée alors
5 c'est important en bonne position pour
empêcher 4 on peut chez les blancs de
prendre de l'espace mais là je ne serais
pas forcément un goût très malin parce
qu on m a dit qu une surface blanche
donc je vous rappelle on a foutu même
couleur et il faut éviter de mettre de
mettre les pions sur sa couleur de cases
l'ambiance 6 5 mai puis on voit de tout
seul plus tard
même s'il ya des exceptions à ça je me
rappelle d'une partie où je me suis
exactement ce que ce que ce trophée a
expliqué mon adversaire et tous ses
pions sur cases blanches ya le foot
cases blanches et j'ai réussi à la peau
mais et c'est évidemment parce que le
cas est un peu critique au final les
pions souvenait bien et reste renier mon
fou et a toujours des contre exemples
mais stouff a énoncé le cas classique le
cas que vous devez connaître pas dire
éviter d'avoir les vos pions sur la
couleur de votre fou ou des fous en
présence la leaf autres cases blanches
parce que
ça peut déjà restreint de votre corps
vous et surtout vous faire attaquer les
pions c'est l'autre problématique ok bon
c'est pas palpitant on va retourner sur
la partie qui nous plaisent un peu plus
stouff on a évidemment la partie grand
des lieux
duda ça va être super intéressant si on
a passé un petit peu de temps et ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'est pas allé voir mon
petit prague
mais là on va aller on va aller le voir
ok elle voit dans l'écran pleine
réflexion
est ici penco il a pris du temps pour
jouer tout ça
on voit que prague il a réussi à
vraiment bien amélioré ces pièces dans
le flou h 4 way le cavalcade
alliot-marie 15e' soutien et peut
toujours aller en d5 un moment
bien joué quand même maintenant il a un
petit plus à peut-être un jour h3g 4h
manger 4c du raje faire
c'est intéressant
d'alger cette attaque c3 mais ce qu'il
veut le prendre ou pas c'est le débat
tout à l'heure qui revient
pas sûr qu'il soit bon à prendre
avait on a parlé un sou voulait jouer
sans ce pion c3 qui est menacé pendant
la finale de c3 te le donne quoi voilà
après il le donne il faut pas que tout
tombe derrière c'est juste la
problématique faut le donner de bonnes
conditions et la dame qui s'infiltrent
c'est peut-être un petit peu embêtant
en tout cas se brade pas il sait pas
trop et si penco comment prendre cette
position je pense ce qu'indique son
temps 1 il a 22 minutes contre une heure
ça va pas du tout parce qu'il va trouver
sa position difficile et on n'a toujours
pas compris on rappelle a pris une
décision qui a laissé cette dans le
début
il a jamais pour l'instant retrouvé
doigt les belles cases imaginait on
voulait que ce cavalier c'est 7 watts en
f 6 ce qui avait été en effet si tu vas
y avait des coups comme cavalier cartes
sont à changer toute la partie
bizarre
pour ses seins de prague en petites
imprécisions alors ils pouvaient
peut-être le données etc mais on voit
qu'il se passe rien de façon maintenant
c'est les blancs qui vont faire leur loi
pas comment il va mettre ça la rend si
toi aussi des petites idées à base de g4
un jour dompteur on encore alexandre
compliqué pour recouvrer la case blanche
par l'adac la grande diagonale blanche
mais j'ai quatre ça pose des problèmes
parce qu'en fait après g45 le f5 dix
fois à peu près 12 et sur f frangé cas
de magie cave à l'étranger 4 bon j'ai
aussi d'un projet graff avec elle cinq
gains mais cavaliers branger 4 avec des
idées des f-5 illizi de venir ici sans
être si sa bonne idée vraiment d'autres
cases noires donc ça reste une
possibilité est pas de suite hein mais
sur le long terme en qui j'ai quelque
peu d'endroits mais on n'est pas loin de
pouvoir cesser 31
d'ailleurs il a joué coup tourbe essien
et à part ça déjà ça en fait on fait
quoi hague les blancs si on veut gagner
cette position si on veut faire nul on
attend mais si on veut gagner je crois
que c'est la seule rupture de
l'échiquier
donc notre jeu de pièces suffira pas
on a amélioré le foulfouldé 3 n'y a pas
de possibilités d'améliorations
supplémentaires on doit quand même tenir
ces quatre la tourelle et là ok les
noirs pareil attendent du coup on veut
faire évoluer la position et donc je
pense que j'ai quatre se trouvent ces
c'est vraiment une possibilité est-ce
qu'on va pas avoir d'ailleurs le couffo
c8 ici
fous ces huit pour empêcher g4 pour
tenir pour être prêt au combat en tout
cas moi j'aimerais bien pouvoir mettre
mon fou en baisse est maintenant on va
surveiller toujours d'investissement
bravo aux cavaliers c'est certain qui
m'énerve depuis tout à l'heure on
voudrait contrôler la case des 5 1 donc
ça c est vrai mais au début le cavalier
de prague dépend 3 donc on aurait pu
prendre les cases le foot n'était pas h
4 e m6 on faisait le travail quoi
non pas d'accord avec la décision et du
coup pas sa meilleure partie et c'est
bien quand je pense qu'ils avaient très
bien joué le début qu'il ait
appris cette mauvaise décision
maintenant il souffre depuis tout à
l'heure
à voir et
ouais n'a pas pas beaucoup bougé j'ai
hâte
là où quelques coups et aux i'm not il
décida de pas mal de choses
on peut retourner voir la partie un peu
fil rouge grande des lieux
artix on a pris le plus de temps et
après faut pas qu'on oublie on avait
promis d'aller voir
une question sur onf équation sur dame
ces six banques en imaginant que ce soit
donc ce retour bcm peut-être à la place
de tours baissé à amadeus je voulais
faire dame c6 bon c'était peut-être pas
trop grave et il fallait vérifier
d'armes français 3
il y avait aussi peut-être d'emprunt ces
trois d'un coup
mais peut-être proposer l'échangé d'un
mac dame 17 aussi souffre c'était
peut-être peut-être faisable
donc il n'y avait pas de d'énormes
problèmes ça gagner pas la partie adams
et 6 il faut faire gaffe aussi parce que
je peux peut-être joué un coup comme
vous vérifiez le tour des cinq
tours si c'était jouable aussi faut
qu'il fasse gaffe amadeus quand un état
d'âme dans le camp adverse on se sent
puissant et ce qui arrive souvent c'est
une bricole sur la dame alors là y'a pas
d'enfermement époux bessette mais faut
vraiment faire gaffe quoi évidemment on
n'est pas loin ouais parce que pour eux
si si si à tour autistes par xamax tu
voulais faire
même qui avait levé cinq ans fait un top
5 de ce trophée avec fougue et cette
db5 le problème c'est que
cavaler le 10 mai
faire attention que sur le jaune citron
vert ça faisait trop de choses à
vérifier par ghislaine meilleure
position il joue stable pour baisser 1
pourquoi pas mais c'est plus humain si
tu veux comme coup dame c6 et
c'est un peu chaud dans une position où
tu es mieux tu as besoin de prendre ce
risque là a clairement pesé beaucoup de
shoots positions différentes à vérifier
alors que là il ya une position de petit
précis et je pense que la clé sera de
passer g4 un moment voilà alors j'allais
partir sur sur grands débuts ce doodle
on peut se la garder on avait dit qu'on
irait vous en avais promis qu'on irait
voir marquants ont travaillé à 5 et
benghazi vainqueur du tournoi du
challenger ou tout à l'heure on était à
peu près dans cette position après
qu'elle ait des deux tours 8 ouais ça
marque ans je suis d'accord avec un v ce
qu'il a fait parce que j'ai envie de
jouer la même chose qu'en valais prend
le cas pour soulager un petit peu j'ai
un pion faible en e2 parce que je suis à
même le croquer mon adversaire mais je
la perds de fou pour compenser donc cas
et c est 6 e 3 je peux enfin gérer le
problème du fouet f1 donc bien joué il a
compris évidemment quelle était
l'urgence de la position ou détroit et
le sort avec tempo avec une petite
tactique à la tactique au service de la
stratégie tout reprend 1,3 à yaffo
achète
donc son adversaire organisé s'est pas
pris cet enfantillage c'est un petit
piège là donc et bien sûr attention
et derrière
b5 à nouveau il a rebouché sont fous
pour l'activer
pour dé
8,8 et chaque pied coups de poing et
maintenant mon cavalier libérer
ces cartes à nouveau donc en fait est ce
que c'est une sur deux propositions de
nul presque 1
mais il ya eu foule f5 on joue on joue
avec les rigueurs zee que le roi est
toujours un tout petit peu plus faible
chez chez les blancs
rouges et liszt ou g6
et
le renard est faible aussi un pack ouais
il est presque j'ai presque du tour m6
et menaces tour projet sis est sûre et
sur oise où son épouse est bien il n'a
pas fait bouger s'il a préféré faire
poids au cices a peut-être parce qu'il
est hors afrique étaient bons joueurs
ouais
le blanc sont parents haïtiens ont
besoin que ce qui pousse maintenant au
pas joué adam attention y'a 15 points 2
1 n'a pas et se faire pigeonner avant un
paillis faire pigeonner le fou vienne
partir est tenue à la casa veut
à 3 c'est pas le bon coup à faire vous
comprenez pourquoi un peu on se prend
quand même avait du coup après six
échecs avaler des cinq sa série avec un
contrôle et si ce contrôle c'est cette
preview date par jour même
donc on va voir quoi comme coup
du gros bien c'est dommage est-ce que je
peux jouer je pas tour 17 comme ça
j'aime bien jouer à trois voies non je
vous reviens au choix
ouais je fais européen
et semblablement 1 place de
deux marques en hockey et il a une
position quand même
voix il va pas perdre je pense pas
le vois bien faire nul
assez logique
et là un petit plus peut-être à pousser
quand même sous parce que comme tu
l'indiquent pas de la problème de dera
ghazi sauf son cavalier en dessin ne
sera pas stable
on y aura lieu 4 comme des 3b en fait
robert tour d2 il faut faire gaffe parce
que si les noirs font trop comme ça
moi je peux aussi mama tirée de la tour
c'est cette fois eu 5 ça peut mal se
passer aussi un oui c'est ça avec deux
échéances en fait si on fait un petit
1 pour des blancs sur le long terme
parce que le fouille en ce sens qui sera
il sera fixé fin il sera stable pour ses
7es places du coup là il faut jusqu'à
vallée des saints que je pense c'est
obligé ouais mais quel dessein et
3 prochainement viril cavale
je pense à tourner même tombée trois
prix à 300 coups qui m'intéresse parce
que j'ai un pack 17 racb 7 et on défend
et je joue aux quatre mains par le cat
de suite d'ailleurs un beau match même
je ferai ce qu'il faut aux cinq
peut-être tranquille ou
faux et 5,3 nekkaz moi un jour je fais
quatre essais de ramener les tours un
peu là haut après sans la colonne sais
c'est un peu dommage quand même parce
que j'ai plus tard c'est cette
cellule est encore jouable ici on s'est
risqué à chaque fois
j'ai calculé vraiment
cette envie magique
et surtout bienvenue à toi cavani
prendre 3 salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent petit à petit
ouais
passer encore intéressant et encore du
jeu mais ça s'appauvrit petit à petit on
grosse partie en tout cas des deux
joueurs belle petite préparation des
noirs qui ont obtenu un tout petit
quelque chose pour pousser mais marquant
s'est très bien débrouillé seul à
vraiment sur la fin de tournoi sur les 5
dernières rondes il a montré pourquoi
s'est-elle plus jeunes grands maîtres
français de tous les temps
ouais gros grosse fin de tournoi en plus
c'est encore plus dur parce que je l ai
fait une grosse fin de tournoi hockey
mais il avait très mal commencé au début
en chaîne et les bulles il était un sur
sept noms se trouve quelque chose comme
ça bien sûr cette donnée sur sept c'est
dur ça reste hockey un très fort joueur
d'échecs un joueur un hyper talent mais
quand vous êtes un hyper talent et que
vous avez pris ben c'est peut-être son
plus mauvais démarrage de tournoi depuis
qu'il joue aux échecs en fait est un
tournoi extrêmement fort parfois avoir
les capacités mentales pour revenir et
on sait que c'est dur parce que on sait
avec souffre dans les tournois qu'on a
ratées bon on n'est plus là m on perd la
confiance on joue moins bien et là un
sur sept on aurait pu penser qu'il avait
abdiqué et faire le pigeon dans le
tournoi pas du tout
il est revenu hyper fort et dès qu'il a
pris son premier point même la nuque on
de morzine avec commence à vraiment être
là et on avait trouvé très fort et après
évident évidemment dès qu'il est revenu
en termes de niveau de confiance baïla
il a fait un excellent
ouais une excellente fin de tournoi donc
même là la partie elle est hyper
intéressante parce que dans l'ouverture
c'est pas si bien passée que ça il a été
plutôt surpris je pense et il s'est
quand même bien tirer du pétrin et
maintenant il a une position tout à fait
tout à fait jouable contre le numéro 1
du tournoi qui a survolé le tournoi donc
c'est encore une grosse partie même s'il
a les blogs c'est quand même plus facile
avec les blancs c'est une grosse
particulier
alors on peut aller glisse je vais avoir
des news pas ce qui s'est passé
est là l ordinateur j'ai vu la courbe en
tout cas qui n'aime pas du tout les
blancs aïe aïe aïe outre des lieux s'il
va rester à sa place visiblement in
angers 5 ya qu on remet juste une petite
couche parce qu'on avait on était là à
peu près avec cavaliers 17 et duda a
trouvé très vite le seul plan le plan
unique parce qu'on avait gshc 6 dingue
les fous bombay irak et sur leur wii
mais doit ce plan il l'avait vu avant de
partir c'est ça qui moi me me soit bien
sûr bien sûr
c'est plus très impressionnant il avait
tout vu avant tout le monde et même
grand delius je suis pas sûr qu'il avait
capté en relation des joueurs
prennent vraiment forme et qu'il n'avait
pas senti de 80g il n'a pas compris la
subtilité des trucs en fait mais le mec
il est quasiment unique c'est profond
parce que différent au niveau entre
entre rend les joueurs ont de l'élite
top 10 mondial c'est quelque chose
prendre grand des lieux c'est plutôt on
va dire un joueur top 50 cent on va dire
ça je pense même si les mondiaux soit en
top 50 c'est 2007 gamin ouais ouais
à 26,5 le chèque c'est top absents donc
voilà une embellie et 80
mais top 10 c'est
c'est un autre niveau préparation sans
doute notre compréhension c'est juste la
folie oui oui c'est vrai que nous
intuitive en alliant les blancs ils vont
tous poussés et vont déchirer les noirs
et on n'avait pas compris non plus ce
petit truc là une fois qu'on l'a sous
les yeux c'est plus facile à expliquer
on avait vu le très intelligent tour g1
de l'ordi là on avait regardé pour voir
comment leur dit traiter la position est
grand dieu s'il n'a pas trouvé la clé de
cette position il a senti qu'il avait
commencé à mal se passer alors là il y
avait un chant qui est intéressant quand
même à expliquer c'est pédagogique
l'idée en fait c'est de fixer le point
de percer on a parlé des points de
percer tout à l'heure en cas de jessains
qu'il avait anticipé sur le fait qu'ils
aient cavaliers prend b3 et un coup
comme à chaque pour fermer un petit peu
la pause et du coup il a voulu fixer
avec 1,5 empêcher les noirs de le faire
une fois que je fais j'ai cinq est sur
b4 il a décidé de n'envoyer la boxe avec
g5
et ça sent bon on a vu qu'à l'âge en
fait un but à la jauge que savait un peu
déconné c'est peut-être pas mieux mais
c'est quand même intéressant souvenant
âge là il faut calculer un an fait
évidemment que si on joue pas les sacs
ici par exemple si je vous parle en
cavale ie2 à la perche de charge des
cinq le réchauffement uac à 5 à 4 et en
fait tomber trois tiroirs des problèmes
et du coup en fait en janvier 5 bat ce
qu'il veut c'est présent cette croix et
privant h6 il ya de fous la tour le pion
à tous nous témoigner sur le sort de roy
mais là après hp g62 l'ont pas trop ce
qu'il veut faire il faut prendre aussi
possible mais quand y'aura être 4 c
voire ouvrir la colonne jerry moyes à
faire un jeu prend et avoir la couenne
fermées en tout cas et toutes vos
actions ok que tu joue maintenant
quelques avec quelle va être la suite
ouais ce qui est pas simple en plus
c'est qu'il ya un cavalier c'est rond
les reins dans toutes les variantes donc
à un moment si on arrive à apaiser
la position
le cavaliere risque d'être en l'air donc
c'est dur il ya beaucoup de choix arrive
et noir
et français 3h plongez vous vérifiez
déjà cette histoire
juste est quand même intéressant de
s'intéresser à des français 3
donc j'ai prêché
il y avoue pranger celles qui étaient
d'un coup sinon mais j'ai pour un
salaire normal
à tour g7 hmm hmm hmm h 30
c'est ce que je voulais justement faire
rage suite tu vois souffre
mais peut-être un autre gain puisque là
c'est pas si claire commun je me cache
derrière les propres pions
en fait là il ya un gars on a vu la
jauge excité de toute façon donc on
pouvait faire une batterie
g6 n'existe jamais avec le four b3 pour
l'instant donc d'alger 3
600 keur
waly prend b3 je pensais que tu allais
jouer
[Musique]
je réussisse à manger comme ça avec
h prend avant ouais enfin voyage bien je
prends et h67 un jour mais après je sais
pas si tu veux manger le kavé d'avancé 5
peut-être avant de le perdre avant avant
de perdre ton ful ouais parce que oui tu
as raison c'est le plus précis je sais
cela qu'il ya à faire oui les noirs ils
n'ont pas pu faire caler prend b3
on peut peut-être faire une nuit de
suite je propose sky prend b3 quand même
c'est plus sérieux pour enlever ce fut
horrible à prend b3 et maintenant pris
ces trois juste pour vérifier
donc je prends un 6
e 5
maintenant c'est cette prise là qui doit
être
peut être difficile à gérer
et tours 8 et là comment on finit
proprement stouff h10 menace
h7 reprendre à mach le
hachis c'est sûr watch fait la fête
l'ordinateur n'est pas d'accord mais
[Rires]
en fait j'ai eu la tête
je me laisse coi 1 ça marche pas parce
qu'il ya me foutais cet appareil a pas
de gymnase de g8
non non non ce faire la
même comment fait-on ici
pas si simple
à la place d'âge 6 est-ce que j'ai pas
de me 3
c'était beaucoup plus simple
se trouvait l'appareil se trouve
monsieur roy je sais tu veux quoi
tour j'ai six projets de mise en
marche bon c'est pas sur moi je pense
quoi
désolé mais marche pas
un bon gars l'air bien
et en plus on bouge les pièces donc pour
les joueurs ça va quand même être
être un petit peu complexe le finir le
boulot
on est combien nous les gars au niveau
bas nous c'est le sait le top français
[Musique]
nous on n'est quand même pas se comparer
au top au top au monde nous on vise le
top top nation c'est déjà pas mal en
plus il ya des gros écarts même au
niveau national déjà en train top 20 top
50 top 100 donc au niveau mondial c'est
du coup tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout qu
[Musique]
est-ce qu on gagne qu'on le découvre
c'est notre patte et combien français
doit être dans le jour c'est 5 30
toujours 50 en fait je suis entre eux
aussi toujours entre la 50e place et 40
le monde meilleur on meilleur rang c'est
en 2009 j'ai des 30
mais bon ces tests est vieux en 2009
c'était la fameuse année
bonjour encore moi je voulais encore
beaucoup et le temps des merlus contre
stouff
n'était pas une perf à l'époque hein
parce que je trouve que j'avais 300
points et l'autre froide plus que lui
voilà une limite il y avait 200
300 points mais ils essayent de me
retourner le couteau regarder a été
malin et dit non non après je suis tombé
dans le panneau et bam
donc moi en 2009 j'étais 24 49 me
rappelle et aujourd'hui je suis 24,48
stouff j'ai fait pas mal de progrès
baba sy du promontoire 2009 et n'en vois
tu embarques préparer ces matches là je
vais perdre 100 points donc
on sait que c'est celle du seigneur à
partager moi je
moi j'étais à 2390 là il ya ya ya
quelques mois et avant l'été en fête
avant l'été français et et j'ai fait un
très très mauvaise et et j'ai perdu
beaucoup de points j'ai perdu 100 points
est-ce que ça festoyer par contre stouff
jeunes en même temps estivaux c'est dur
de vendre non mais non franchement je
suis sans voix
juste juste bah en fait j'arrive pas
quoi oui oui quand ça commence on ne
savait pas et en fait du coup du coup
c'était vraiment va juste mauvais
soissons
j'avais des mauvaises police fasse genre
en espagne j'ai fait un tournoi par
équipe j'avais la première partie je
suis à +6 je perds deuxième partie je
sais c'est une finale nulle part un
grand m je perds je prends ta tuque ont
un coût lendemain joue un mètre de 1400
chapitre iv je perds est en fait tout
est parti c'est hallucinant et en fait
c'est si à chaque fois de me remettre et
c'est de maturité mais en fait à la fin
basterds aussi de quoi mais j'ai quand
même fini par gagner rien n'a pas
retouché vote sur m mais abbey non en
fait mais ouais mais bon enfin c'est
mais finit souvent non et j'ai perdu
beaucoup de points et maintenant je gère
des pires lots de ma vie clairement mais
mais du coup bah ça va remonter ouais
mais bon faut faire le même mental que
marquant il a montré la voie le petit
jeune même action 1 sur 7 il est revenu
et tout va revenir
avec du coup de buzz du coup je peux m
enfin je suis maître fide mais du coup
pour être maître international il savoir
trois normes de m et 2400 et l'au delà
explique moi je suis content normes de
maître et que vous prenez plus me le
faut mais j'ai pas eu de lots suffisant
ils montrent que 10 points ouais c'est
souvent problème
j'avais eu le même problème pour passer
m c'était le hello énorme c'était ok et
loi mais ça fait a fait plus de 1000 c
est ce que j'aime et nantes quand même
horaire ces radios est-ce que j'ai
arpenté tous les lots entre 2380 et
c'est bon j'ai eu pendant toute ma vie
j'ai eu 23 50 24 quoi mais jamais eu les
2400 et c'est ce qui me manquait là je
pollue sans croire donc là je suis très
mais
je sais que ben je suis pas très loin on
va prendre les langues qu'on veut jouer
là bas il faut que je rejoue et que ça
ça va revenir mais même si en fait d
assez bizarre mais on a besoin de ça
enfin moi j'ai eu le même souci ce
trophée c'est quand j'ai obtenu mon vélo
le plus bas j'ai bien j'ai bien réagi tu
vois j'étais redescendu
pour psychologiquement dire mais qu'est
ce que je fais là et après c'était passé
mais
garde tout à 21,80 oui et puis après
j'ai fait une série de tournois et je
suis sentie à 2309 ou 8 ans tout comme
ça oui et donc j'ai pas dû quasiment 100
points et là j'ai fait j'ai fait le
tournoi de vendeurs j'ai fait une norme
de m bon à la 4e une ronde avant la fin
en plus et est d'ailleurs j'ai fait
faire un podium à vandoeuvre parce que
si je faisais contre christian bauer et
ben j'aurais pu j'aurais pu voir les
avait une tribune peut-on d'ailleurs
j'aurais dû faire bref et du coup après
j'ai fait d'autres tons noirs en équipe
j'espère bien jouer je veux entendre
après la grèce il y avait je suis monté
de 2309 à 90 est en fait du coup je suis
vachement je suis vachement
[Musique]
c'est moi c'est les montagnes au fil
d'un style aussi tranchant qui a
expliqué un petit peu ça mais là c'est
trop trop les montagnes c'est vrai que
c'est embêtant de rater deux ratés
d'aussi peu parce qu'on sait que
c'est juste deux victoires contre 2 m et
tu les as déjà fait mais pas au bon
moment ou quoi
mais je vois je vois très bien j'avais
raté le type de mettre à un point et
lohouès j'ai obtenu le titre trois ans
plus tard tu vois je t'ai passé 23 91
virtuel donc ça c'était hyper dur
mentalement et après j'avais joué nous
avons joué une partie je me rappelle aux
jeux pas du monde contre chronos offre
un grand maître assez connu heureusement
il est il est plus de ce monde
aujourd'hui mais mais du coup j'étais
gagnant 40e et si je le bats je faisais
je passais les 24 du coup j'ai fait que
nul je suis passé 23 96 qu'au 40e j'ai
pas joué le coup que j'avais vu je me
suis je joue au 41e il m'a empêché de le
faire je pouvais le plus chaud 41e et du
coup à cause de ça tu passe pas mais
très brave c'était la même année donc
j'ai attendu trois ans donc c'était dur
1to toute cette période là de trois ans
tu watts il ya un point et l'eau et un
couffin tu vois c'était la totale quoi
mais ça fait partie partie du jeu et il
y en a qui ont plus de réussite il y en
a qui passent juste d'un
prêt une fois les 24 et du coup bon ba
et ba
ouais c'est clair donc du coup avoue
quelques questions moi ma meilleure perf
sont déjà parlé c'était je ne veux pas
tu as un indien à
2600 gupta au tournoi de
terrain corse à porticcio
et et firouz que je lui envoie sur
l'internet et
fraisse je l'avais joué en top 12 une
énergie est perdu et sur la vallée noire
philidor bon ferait citer les ultra
forts et toi tu en es où toi ta mère
père fois le rectorat c'est aussi court
no sauf parce que dans l'histoire en
2005 j'ai joué court no soft tu vois ils
étaient
26 68 ans et je les rejoins qu'on était
26,53 jeu pas d'europe adultes et je lui
avait collé avec les noirs donc c'était
c'était c'était vraiment bien et j'ai
battu quelques 26 quand même en fait à
l'époque maintenant je perds fait plus
aucune perte maintenant je suis stable
se trouve tu vois je fais vraiment je
bats avant j'avais du mal à battre les
plus faibles sur le papier et maintenant
je suis plus régulier mais je suis plus
aucune perte voilà voilà la
problématique stouff faudrait les deux
et
du coup j'ai battu est en ruine l'ami
aussi qui fait le tata steel des
challengers
les plus de 26 et pas facile j'ai battu
ce veto chine c'est un fait en grand
maître aussi j'ai battu des jets battu
ben en fait les gros les gros les
grosses stars de ma catégorie bas que
sont sébastien mazet et mathieu cornette
en fait je les ai pas joué en jeunes
alors que normalement je n'étais pas
aussi fort que mais je devais jouer
contre eux et à chaque fois je craquais
mes choix de français eux les gagner et
je désire jouer en étant adulte et je
suis très positif puisque j'ai battu
sébastien sur la seule partie qu'on a
fait ensemble et mathieu la première
fois qu'on a joué j'ai collé et après on
a fait deux matches nuls donc pour
l'instant je reste positif mais il faut
plus trop les jouer parce que ça se
passera pas comme ça tout le temps
ça sera ouais c'est chaud quand même
mais ça s'est bien passé étonnamment
parce que j'étais déjà il était
quasiment 26 quand je l'avais joué et et
25 96 je me rappelle et mathieu était
déjà très fort grands maîtres à 25 50 il
ya aussi pas mal d'entre eux 25 50 et
petit 26 juste en dessous et du coup
voilà les quelques pertes mais j'ai fait
ma nul contre vachier lagrave et la
nuque on ne joue bavasser les mecs à
plus de 2007 contre qui j'ai fait j'ai
fait nul quoi donc ça c'est les petites
pertes et voilà pour pour faire ma pub
sur nos nos pertes souffre on a on a eu
des bons mais on a aussi fait des
comptes repères fin
alors c'est quoi la plus grosse contre
perf en étant juin prochain
comment la plus grosse perf contre paire
ce que tu as eue en étant plus de 23 on
va dire de [ __ ] et maître fide coincé
alors c'est toi la tienne parce que moi
je pense que je te bats a alors
oui en fait depuis que je suis maître
jeu alors perdu ou nul tu vois alors nul
j'ai fait une news contraint 1800 je me
rappelle une fois à l'open de gains
entre
1050 par des fêtes basse je crois que
c'est presque toi je crois
qu'il me dit il mais j'avais pas de
chichis
je sais que j'ai en fait
quand j'avais la grippe au think loi
j'ai perdu contre 1 2106 que
normalement je sais pas mais je gagne
pas non plus qu'on est plus forts
j'expliquais je gagne plus depuis que je
suis maître en tout cas non g
je vois en fait si tu des plus forts
avec ton éloge de 2150 je crois à
l'époque quand j'avais perdu contre toi
et le mec il était 2100 aussi est
quelqu'un gagne en
plus complètement la partie était
intéressant tout ça mais qu'on de l'eau
de magna à 2100 savait pas été très
convaincant il avait fait pas mal
d'erreurs stratégiques et j'étais
vraiment pas en forme et bon faut pas
chercher des excuses en tout cas j'ai
perdu mais il attend qu'une grosse
partie quoi il n'avait pas fait une
grosse partie c'est ça le pire quoi
c'était la totale quoi
mais moi je suis pire que vous encore
moi j'avais j'avais joué un tour en noir
et en fait c'était marrant parce qu'en
fait j'arrive à l'open de condom
donc pour moi je cherche un peu la fête
tu vois mais c'est un rondin donc la
ronde 1 j'avais pas encore fait la fête
à priori et du coup je jouais contre 1
du 900 pour moi j'avais j'avais 22 80 et
juin 1900 qui faisait forfait en date
qui vit qui t'ai pas vu il avait oublié
et du jeu voir avec du vieux
quand je commence à taquiner les 23 à
tous
et je dis bon ben je j'aimerais bien
essayer le jeu pour une norme quand même
tu vois fin bien revenir sur bien sûr
tu as plus de normes quoi et du coup bon
donc se voir leurs titres sur l'histoire
de tas de la plus grosse cote repères du
coup ça va être énorme on discute il me
dit ami un joueur qui en fait mais oui
mais on va tâcher bon exemple donc
arrête il me ferait contre le moins
forts du tournoi il avait 14 152 56
14 50 et il avait il avait quoi ils
avaient tous trois ont quoi et
moi d'avoir la remise aux normes trouve
même adversaire il me dit
il mais qu'attend prokin défense il va
m'aider je dis moi enfin 12 pour l'heure
pour le projet pour j'ai pris la partie
un petit peu vraiment trop à la légère à
l'époque j'étais vraiment comme ça en
fait tu veut s'initier à une ferme et
est juste pour te donner l'exemple
à un moment donné il met un fonds 1,6 tu
sais et dans la sienne fermé et j'ai pas
encore rockets et du coup moi
franchement vous dire un freeze de
l'épreuve les mots que vous employez
mais comme un connard que je suis
notamment sur x h67 du rock et après tu
as un plan de 4 6% à 4 et moi je me suis
dit moi je voulais jouer vite et donc
sur sur chance sur x h 6 j'ai joué chez
surcroît et fuite en me disant bas il va
manger c'est sûr on apprend en effet
h144 et je m'aperçois que
du coup je fais ça donc si ceux ci
visaient sur roya fuite s'il veut
vraiment se foutent de ma gueule et que
j'ai fait aux 3 il revient avec son
foulard
bon du coup il a joué un léger ce roi et
fit stouff il a joué un coup et là j'ai
joué cavalier g8 pour forcer à manger
angers7 roy prend après je cherche à
cacher et la turquie et les bété [ __ ]
de tout scandale et après j'ai perdu
deux pions jardel et je fais un jeu tout
ce monde et et je me prends dames c'est
saddam ses trois échecs d'un français 5
en fait je perds deux tons j'ai perdu
deux tons d'ouverture et j'étais des
rockets enfin c'est un cauchemar il
réussit à récupérer les deux pions en
commun comme un lion en quoi ça va le
perdre en mouvement c'est ce qu'on se
dit non et tellement et franchement il a
en plus il n'a pas fait une mauvaise
partie est bon bah j'ai perdu et donc
voilà donc j'avais j'avais 22 80 et j'ai
perdu
avec pas touche et il a raconté une
belle aussi je me rappelle de mathieu
cornet qui m'a raconté une partie aussi
comme ça
et me dit ouais jouer jouer à un
retraité genre à 18,50 ou 19 cents et je
me rappelle qui m'a raconté justement
que le mec avait ultra bien joué bon ok
mature et peut-être pas fait sa partie
de sa vie mais il ya huit tous les coups
du tennis et puis bah et là ils sont
n'étaient jamais sortis et mathieu il
était déjà quasiment 25 donc c'était des
grosses briques 14,50 normalement ben on
à la marge mais pas tous jeunes ou non
mettre une belle aussi avec avec le 15
cents à 22,50 vous êtes
vous êtes un peu copains de galère et au
le paraître façon pas tout on a même
profil
sauf que lui les maîtres
mais on a le même profil
est marrant
du coup on a une petite pause devant les
partis de la mairie très très joli coup
de duda dans cette position d'ailleurs
puisqu'on voit que ryanair d'avoir des
grosses compensation pour les blancs
c'est un peu ce qui vise l'ouverture de
la position et là il a fait f6
fermeture de la position parce que sur
fg fg et la torah tag la dame donc
j'aurai le temps de prendre le cavalier
ou qui va le faire gagner fg oui donc
mars pas tu vois qu'il ya eu un coup
après maranda méritoire
bc3
et je n'avais pas vu de grandes et luce
il a fait
et d'où de la rater aussi visiblement
est-ce qu'il veut jouer
à des jeux 2 500 autres arbustes ou fils
pouvait jouer cinq cents autres soit à
tout cas et français où pranger 7 waouh
et ça a été oubliés on voit que les
joueurs et commence à oublier des coups
bas qu'il devrait voir en tout cas à
duda il a été tellement fort dans cette
partie il avait il avait plein de temps
évident mais de la cam sur duda parce
que j'ai envie de voir voir sa petite
tête là
ça va être
rigolo well regardez regardez voilà est
directe il est pas content
il est il et des
guest à vue
regarde regarder un petit peu on voit un
la dou da il est
il est direct il est pas content après
lui parce que fout g7 c'est super simple
on lui pour un joueur comme lui parce
qu'il doit les ventes forcées de
sacrifices on aa ou dur
coup dur pour jan christoph voilà aïe
aïe aïe on voit on voit pas ces gens
enfin depuis hier on en voit quand même
des belles gaffes et ça sent la une
parce que alors qu'à ce qu'ils devaient
jouer parce qu'on ne sait pas si facile
à six a gaffé mais normalement est il
avait prévu se rendre depuis un moment
il se pensait super gagnant
et willy l'odyssée prend b2
way a tant attendu coûts attendues d'un
me 3 oui on faisait ou 5 d'abord ce que
je disais oui
ou 5
et s'est terminée à dos ou pas à la fois
s'être quand même hein donc c'était quoi
le coup gagnant en fait
au moins il pouvait gagner parce qu il
peste mais c'était pas si facile bonfoh
proche des 7 doigts le voir n'a pas vu
c'est pas normal là peut-être peut-être
dame si ce n'est se défend g7 et comme
cobayes débauche d'effets ou prend 1,4
pour regarder un coup comme même en fait
tous rêvent 7 se fout là il partant
ainsi la case b6 quand même pardon
excusez moi sauf pardon dams et s'est
améliorée quand même fou christina est
des fous b6 alors c'était peut-être pas
si simple
mine de rien on
finalement ne masque en fait ce qui est
frustrant pour duda c'est pour ça qu'il
pleure entre guillemets c'est de ne pas
avoir vu vous prendrez 7 on lui c'est
juste l'horreur mais souffre pas si
facile
alors c'est prend b2 c'était pas
possible france à l'îlot parce que j'ai
un ami policier après bp en c3
alors ça vous arrive de choper des
superpositions mais sans vraiment le
faire exprès ah bah oui oui ça peut
arriver ça peut arriver de
être
soi revient secouer de se retrouver se
retrouve bien ou inversement des fois
vos adversaires on a réussi des fois
c'est vous
allez on prend ce rapide et un fils et
sa licorne bah si tu fais prise bête
après fo pranger ça tu risques d'être
exposé à [ __ ] en bétonnant you
alors qu'ils b2 je suis pas sûr que ça
soit
ou prend b2 c'est hyper risque et non
que tu laisses tous les tours j'ai cinq
dans de meilleures conditions peut-être
cru et on voit les trophées de fer prise
baie de rio au roi est trop trop faible
il faut manger le fou g7 pas de choix
mais juste pour pour finir comment ici
on voit bien là je vais clair les
avantages noir
et photo op la pièce sans cependant tout
projet 7
73 7 5 je fais une chasse aux faux
peut-être ces tours fc est quand même
avec le 5 après je fais une chasse au
fuse à chasse aux faux est ouverte est
ce que ça marche alors ça
ah non
path to fed mois on toi c'est une
position pour toi se trouve
alors j'avais pensé adams et 7 pour
cavaler bush le premier 4
mai sur dame c 'est tuera phobie 6
donc avoir
d'atomes bessette mesdames becel j'y
crois pas
parce que tu as lors d'un bébé sept
cavaliers eux deux
je mange au 4
rue des forges et wave 3
oui d'accord
l'un d'accord est sûre d'un média non
mais bon en fait il était que je voulais
faire alors avec dams et 7 pour menacer
m'attend c'est 2 mai 1 à 4 peut-être car
à 4 quelque chose comme ça a la même
mieux quand même dans la même manche
prend 1,4
ouais je sais pas c'est pas limpide
encore
maman je réserve nettoie tout reste aux
deux premiers 3 donc fait qu'elle
mangeait des pions
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans mais
cette fois ci je pouvais le faire à la
place de manger e4
bien voir comme on n'a pas trouvé qu'on
va aller voir après on va aller voir
après tout ce que nous dit lignot dans
le tchat
du coup c'était bien dame b cette cour
où 1,5 et dames bessette voilà les deux
variantes d'un bep set mais il a oublié
fou prend g7 dont alors lille il me dit
quoi des princes et rois
donc fou prend g7 hockey
roi prend g7 après et après tout
reprendre et 5
ouais ça va être ça la partie
vraisemblablement pour prend
non mais ça c'est apparemment ces mêmes
même dead
oui en fait et c'est pas sûr qu'il ya un
coup sous tu peux pas les en h on tour
j'ai six gagne
donc je
compile une surprise dans prend 3 h 7
voilà je fais chaque échec et tour g1 et
dames c est quand même là et chaque
métier à damas qui est cher je me suis
engagé à tour g7 ok ok ok extraction du
roi non mais c'est pas trop pour toi
mais c'est pour montrer qui aura bien
matt pour la balade
c'est ce que dame g63 chu de tours gère
là j'avais peut-être dame si c'est oui
je bosse que tu as dimanche c'est donc
là on ne lâche pas donc ça veut dire que
duda peut pas bouffer angers7
pour ça qu'ils peignent on a du coup
c'est la crise parce que du coup
quasiment il est vraiment fort en plus à
toulouse de manger h 6 devant g5 et quoi
ces mets d'ailleurs je pense qu'on est
encore au moment où défend
mais ça va me coûter un seul cette
histoire ainsi
en plus en rose c'est pas très dur et
avoir pour le g20 non mais là il aurait
dû le voir c'est pour ça qu'ils
les autres coûts était pas facile on
voit que ce n'est pas si facile de
prendre l'aventage mais il aurait pu
trouver ian christophe et raté un coup
aussi facile que fou prend g7 sans
l'avoir regardé ce qu'il n'a pas regardé
clairement
donc là
[Musique]
je crois que c'est ici peut-être que les
lieux voulait prendre en b2 en ce à
quoi
ouais du coup le roi peut pas prendre g7
ouais c'est ça bon d'accord oak de coûts
prises b2 peut-être que tu proposes et
de thaler ça me faisait hyper riche et
complet est ce que je serai obligé à me
faire voir prendre du coup parce
qu'après ça varois prend et te dire
maintien ou robin et je te le dis bah
tiens après changes achetées soit
fait pour être obligé de balancer la
cale
est ce qu on compterait pas avec eux
[Musique]
c'est plus fou prend un schisme la
menace tous fait les fallout même si
rejouera j'attends toujours faire fou
proches ils sont plus c'est ça
donc je vois pas pourquoi ici si vous
voulez plus je regarde la position je
comprends le désarroi de de duda et je
me dirais mais en fait je suis peut-être
foutu je verrai d'hector vie parce que
ça m'intrigue trop large ouais c'est la
fin de championnat comme dit fatou et du
coup double en train de regarder quelque
chose il va essayer de trouver mais il a
pris un coup sur la casquette et se dit
mais comment j'ai pu rater ça et même
grande des lieux s'il dit
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qu'il a vu et il sait que
c'est rien
c'est vraiment pas facile
ah
non pas du tout c'est de comprendre un
truc
mais en fait
[Musique]
la différence moi
je comprends pas
vraiment dur en tout cas
un bon mal de
gérer ce gros problème
on en tout on entend toutes tes analyses
toof
ouais mais j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi ça marche pas
et pendant ce temps-là amadeus innu mais
les petits salut à toi au lit tôt il
nous met les petits détails du match
entre medvedev et nadal voilà
des coups
alors parce qu'il nous faut un jeune
rencontré une variante tu vas devenir
fou je crois déjà là j'ai dû beaucoup de
mal et je pense que c'est pareil pour
duda c'est pas fameux non plus tous les
mois où tu vas bouger les pièces par
serait trop compliqué moi je suis ta en
fait on cible la défense mais elle est
introuvable ah oui en fait ici reprend
g7 alors jours apprend le 7e tour j'ai
cinq prises prise wife cette
sas à faire un bref cette fin ouais
roi 8 dames g6 roi des 8es ont fait que
l'enfant tour
wpt à ses sept
tours prend
dans prend
saignant voilà le pion est vraiment trop
fort ok ça gagne à cacher je fais ça
c'est
du coup marié au début
donc on a vu de la santé cinq fort coup
avoue j'ai cette réforme ce qui n'a raté
est ici un bon coup prison b2
de l'idiot alors fou prend on l'a dit qu
il faut jouer cinq
croit bien meilleure course était
vraiment intéressant baj que je veux 5
et du coup oui mais c'est dur parce que
tour g5 un g6 quand même donc fallait
oui je mets mes mais du coup c'est ce
que cherchent les noirs
après ce que cela change maintenant
alors on va regarder la smart europe
prend b2 d'abord à part dont
roy prend b2 et ben là tu manges et 7
est assez nul
or moi je me suis dit waouh
pourquoi ça fait nul en fait ça change
quoi au fait que je me rends en b2 donc
la même pour f1 donc de 3 8 à 6
ok voilà je vends je rejoins d81 oui
c'est vrai
tu prends voilà tu manges et surtout
reprendre celui d'un procès 8 h 6 c'est
bien le 4 est en fait la différence
c'est que son temps prend 1 kg d'un
match plus que l'échec d'un point à 6
et à la fin j'ai qui va le pion c'est la
seule
ça fait nul et c'est la seule manière de
l'obtenir et du 28e a déjà
en phase est trouvable si tu vois la
première à lui les gaffes et dio avait
du coup si je prends mais tu vois tu
peux
il est ko et c'est vrai qu'après une
adulte un mot comme il vient de faire et
quand même que ça a été
a été jouée la mangue ou deux voilà une
courroie berne robin est le meilleur
coup j'ai pas regardé encore pourquoi
mes robert assaël
oui mais du coup là du coup la ligne
doit être gagnante un roi j'essaie pour
projet 5h projet
a5a et là je crois que ça gagne on va
laisser à 3 fin évidemment aussi je
crois que c'est la même ligne je vérifie
juste un nom c'est parce que là quand
c'est trop compliqué comme ça en main
leurs biens vous savez qu'on me falloir
du temps
mais
mais mais des fois
en gros ça va être la même
sauf que là du coup voilà c'est mon
frère est pas facile par contre pour
grandes hélices maintenant que duda a
pris en b2 il faut trouver le bon coup
il faut comprendre que reprend ça gagne
pas de damas chute après tu peux te dire
bon jeu peut fort bien tranquille je
suis sûr qu à rien
parce que en fait tout robert tu peux tu
touré veut s'en rend trop calculer mon
cul oui oui ben en fait roi bea ils
vérifient mais c'est normal en plus
c'est le genre de coups que l'on joue
dans ce genre de position pour garder le
pinot noir et là il peut aussi se dire
bon reprend b2c encore plus simple voilà
voilà qu'on aime il peut gaffé avec roi
promet de 1 c'est pas facile de voir
faut prendre quatre à la fin quand même
non bien sûr mais il peut gâcher ma
presse en calcul et tu peux trouver le
bon coup parce que tu peux te dire
comment les deux ça peut te mettre plus
tard dans des
[Musique]
dons qu
il a pris en baie de new du fils qui
regarde il regarde la caf il a il a pris
v2 c'était pas facile de le trouver roye
b 1 est-ce que
et mesrine est bien sûr non plus il a
peut-être joué prise b2 mais il ya
peut-être entre guillemets rien derrière
j'avais tout trouvé
on va voir mais en tout cas maintenant
rapporte doit manger juste un simon
s'il mange pas des sept pays les maths
enfin je crois moi je prends h 6 h le
matin donc je pense
je pense que que là il va manger g7 en
tout cas c'est souvent un bon gamin
abandonne encore 17 et l'archipel
français de france avant tout les gars
qu'on a qu'on a vues entre
viddy enfin visite les hier c'était gros
la dou da c'est une grosse gaffe pour
lui quand même ce qui s'est passé
et les verts pas sûr tu vois qu'il est
en jeu c'est pas si et si et si la vue
là l'air dépité
et leurs députés mais mais il a
peut-être vu un le pays peut aussi faire
de l'acting
voilà ce poste là stouff voilà
je soude amateurs un cinéma voilà
en tout cas c'était ultra chaud
mais en tout cas c'est une belle garde
de duda qui avait fait une grosse grosse
partie quand même contre grand des lieux
s'il était pas loin de régler noir de
lui coller et là il a fait un oubli
monstrueux wa kira mme
way
se surveiller sous fin s'il ya des
évolutions prague il est toujours un peu
le même style de posy même si j'ai
l'impression qu'il est pas mal peyriac
in
c'est plus du tout la même partie 1 est
là vers gagnant contre visite
on ira voir tout ça évent de forest hill
travail mais c'est pas encore fait son
histoire
et la partie les
il n'a pas l'air dépité là
[Musique]
ouais tout à l'heure il était était
vraiment green
mais il va s'accrocher peut-être
là sont en fait là y'avait que oui il ya
que reprend g7 comme
homme coup à cause de la menace vous
prend un cheese donc en fait il est sûr
de trouver mais un peu par défaut
à part s'il abandonne bêtement un stuff
une paire pas en fait cette position de
tout ce qu'on a vu ses forces et se
forcer un
maintenant qu'il y aura prend b2
d'aller pour moi c'est un fin nul parce
qu'on fait dans des lieux s'ils avaient
apprécié autant -
renforcer tout reprend forces éprises
d'un prompt retour des tours f1 voit
tout et forcé jusqu'à la fin est ce que
je vais faire mon résultat
pour qui
ce fatras
mais prague il parlera pas je pense qu
on reste au nom il perdra pas en reste
au statu quo
j'avais aussi la belle victoire de
grands delius mais si prague gagne
c'était quand même là même le même
classement quoi donc pas d'évolutions
majeures en tout cas partie partie à
rebondissements ici
alors que
comme d'hab
donc et amadeus qui nous fait le récap
du tennis et
voilà 21 grand chelem est pas mal
j'ai une question qui viennent on aurait
permis de faire la pub où il a passé six
silhouettes à raison excusez moi oui oui
oui on n'a pas fait la pub de dents il
est quelle heure on l'a on l'a
maintenant le nom à temps je sais plus
ici on a fait de la pub à fait non mais
on a fait deux pubs
maintenant mais là je regarde dans le
ça ne l'a pas fait complètement oublier
la pub armes tant la partie elle est
vraiment est vraiment excitante celle là
et du coup c'est le bon moment comme ça
apprend ce fait les high note juste
derrière la plus beaux gosses parfaits
voilà c'est cool et ben ok on vous dira
d'abord suite les amis minutes
et je lance ce la petite pub a tout de
suite
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les parties à la avec nous revoilà
et sa déroute raconter des bêtises il en
pleine forme tout fin pour cette fin de
ta dah style il a vraiment envie à fond
de parler et chaque je peux vous le dire
les variantes de folie
toutes les positions convoi on va vous
parler tout ce que vous voulez alors du
coup et tu vois c'est ça s'est produit
un souffle sur sur l'échiquier c'est la
partie et ouais et on va avoir droit
vous prend 1,4 un fan variantes qui a
été raté par un grand des lieux sinon
ils avaient l'air il a peut-être compris
maintenant parce qu'il a la position
sous le nez que c'est la position
critique mais on vous rappelle à un gros
coup oublier pour
ré pour
haut doubs da et il s'en sort bien
puisqu'il a réussi à trouver ses prend
b2 alors un plus ou moins forcé en fait
tout était forcée pour lui roi promet 2
c'est une petite gaffe et c'est pas
facile à avoir de voir pourquoi ces
souffre qui nous a tout expliqué et on
avait jeté un oeil à la hors 10,1 à ce
moment là dans cette variante très
calculatoire là les blancs sont presque
gagnant en prenant à tour et en envoyant
pion à dame sauf que le roi on vient de
le mettre en début de variantes en b2 et
du coup ça laisse une opportunité assez
incroyable au
au noir dans cette position on peut
estimer grande et l'usv a fait retour
france et 8 ont pas perdre de temps dans
france et 8 menace damas huit ans pas
mal de variantes dont la vente à chis ou
prend 1,4 en plus c'est pas de bâle
souffre parce qu'on n'a pas d'âme g7
achète on n'a rien de tout ça donc on
est obligé de prendre un peu à ma suite
et dans le pion saute nasa et alors
qu'avec le roman bien c'est gagné et
séoul en fait ouais c'est pas de bol
mais non plus de problèmes de son et en
fait je trouve quand il est quand il est
chez son pote là il a une très bonne
connexion et c'est nickel au top en fait
c'est avec ça me ferait même de son au
début pour la configuration mai
mais bon ça va ouais du coup assez
incroyable cette partie gaffe mais gaffe
sur gaffe mais sur garde de grandiose
peut-être plus dur avoir encore que il
aurait pu trouver
et c'est vrai qu'on vous envoie bien il
aurait pas eu ce problème enfin deux
variantes et on remonte la variante 1 là
on n'a pas
exactement la même chose et tous les
échecs on regagne une tour et là
maintenant on est gagnant quoi avec la
chine je surfe ou prend 1,4 simplement
faire en prendre quatre une option est
très avancé est celui là ne vaut rien
incroyable
on comprendra plus tard et là on va
gagner avec milan vote m
mais la dame angers7 on gagne facilement
aïe aïe aïe ou dur alors on va faire un
petit tour petit tour des stades du coup
peut-être
avec ton petit prague
type rallye
alors est en train de travailler un
donc alors on était à peu près là je
vois la coupe du monde et la chine
pour eux si je vais vous mettre la cam
comme ça vous serez encore mieux ma vie
en valais d'un petit c'est bon c'est bon
ça et pratiquer gagnant
up il est à bloc et si benko et mal
autant donc tour 6
à 4 bon coup pour enlever le cas et b6
enlever la pression est prêt à garder
l'idée c'est qu'à et des cinq lors
cavaliers prend des cinq tout le monde
voit dame prend des 5 pertes de la tour
le coutour heures c'est très fort aussi
tour et je gagne la colonne et je peux
rentrer ça a l'air d'être dur aussi
du coup il a fait faux bessette
pour prendre six cavaliers prend 1,6
maintenant tour à tour permal
dame 17 a été jouée apparemment là y
avait un gros coup gagnant
quoi le coup gagnant souffre
gdf suez déjà
la vallée f6 tour prend
pas pardon et par mois des gagnants
c'est pas très gagnant non effet les
tactiques de malades habitude là c'est
quoi cette tactique qui va nous
expliquer parce que parce que tout à
l'heure j'ai triché j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient cavaliers investissement fait un
tas oubliée il ya encore un coup des
meneurs il ya eu
c'est pas joué et je t'ai pas un piège
là il ya un gain par avant parce que tu
as et lacour bah qui nous le donne il ya
un gars a cherché à trouver
[Musique]
est un petit coup de
pas si facile
d'amener un jeu c'est pas d'âme des uns
c'était assez coquin la
bouche et parce que tu penses de dames d
un thunder france vrai je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient pensé trop dans de bonnes
conditions
pour attaquer ça ça donne l'impression
un peu partout
rigolo
il ya eu d'alger 3 tours fc est à la
proposition est l'art du rhin pour les
noirs d'alger 3 c'était pas le bon coup
et tous rêvent pas non plus
alors est ce qu elles mêmes gains puis à
cavaler f6 toujours est juste pour
vérifier dans la position précédente
alors c'était quoi le gain km2 et u7
gagner aussi bon apparemment maintenant
ça va être perdu cette position au
retour elle fait comment finissent à
proprement
un cavalier m6 et déjà déjà hyper dur
un vague annie et maintenant
pas de problème là dessus
peut-être imagine si si si gagner que
one forez finit par part
blender goudé partagent certainement
bout quoi
[Musique]
salariés voient parfois même il ya
toujours ce petit plus c'est ça et il
faut sur le sable à une forêt
en hiver
n'ont pas se laisser faire par le petit
bonhomme là
alors et cariat qui va gagner je pense
trop de problèmes
we
say die a une occasion en or en
franchement nuda lui a donné la partie
il n'y a pas trouvé et ça y est on a une
position critique
regardez ça qu'on avait vu c'est
ceci en route gradius la veille un parti
un
rendez-vous s'il a battu en labatut qui
déjà
les vignes a pas longtemps il a battu
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut voir
mais il n'a pas été parfait
il a battu il a battu vraiment celui qui
a été battu facilement après par le cos
vide balayé bon à chis de grands des
lieux c'est maintenant on aura le fou
prend 4 qui doit être que coup fort
c'est ici pour
on adam g 7 h est la jouer directement
partie fil rouge maintenant je vous le
dis depuis un petit moment
cette variante
wii fait vous savez tous ri
pak
à la salle joue plus vite face à face à
faire annuler un peut-être je pense que
tu peux changer ou au ps vous allez voir
ouais bah je pensais que ça allait le
dénouement peut-être là mais sait pas
s'il va bouger le roi il verdun prend
ainsi ses dames c'est qu'à propos de
l'influencé
4,6 et à 6 donc du coup il va devoir
choisir moi je pense que ça va quoi
du coup l on va où on va voir juste
jarden est-ce qui va gagner ça imprécis
mais
le roi est bien placé je pense que il
n'a pas réussi à gagner s
[Musique]
au
dam c4 à défendre dans la caméra
est joué et que là du coup les joueurs
sont balèzes deux camps
geroy 7 d'un prend 1,6 propose le jeu
pensant
non il a fait ça il a joué avec un
chèque il fait des échecs
bon ça va tout est question de goût
alors est ce que pense on vous laisse là
comme sûre mais il est des grandes
hélices qui est si vous voulez l'a
compris
je suis évidemment pas ce qu'il s'est
dit mas je me prends fou prend 1,4 et si
jamais mon roman b1 et j'ai hâte de voir
ils vont en discuter je suis sûr qu'ils
vont en discuter ils ont tous les deux
vu en fait après
une radio où se trouvaient les montrer à
gaz bien
que d'autres à cause de la
vase hinton me tombe bien devant
met toi bien devant
as he garde à vue
tout fuite et l'autre à vue ils sont
d'accord ils ont tout vu mais après je
suis le spoiler alert aujourd'hui je
vous colle absolument tout ce qui se
passe sur l'échiquier or de l'échiquier
de parquet est la même que la casse bien
vous l'avez vu
et
l'a montré la case rien à voir là on la
sentait
obligatoires
on leur dit parier tout ça mais je
[Musique]
ressentais à sa santé l'histoire a
souvent qu'on a laissé la cave vous avez
bien compris
comme le doigt sur un casus belli et à
la fois il s'en sort bien grandi ce
qu'ils avaient été dominés par un très
fort duda et bouddha fait une
catastrophe un moment et derrière il n'a
pas trouvé la clé il aurait pu aussi un
grand élu ce bon voilà qui pratique de
fin de tournoi alors vers qui on va
maintenant est-ce que tu voir ton petit
prague finirait spinco je pense qu'on va
de mada dessus voilà c'est pas une
roulotte
au pas qu'on oublie d'aller voir aussi
donc il ya bien il ya bien la grosse
qualité les 15 - affaibli et la poubelle
pour pour
au récit penco donc ça va être
maintenant fini dans pas longtemps on
peut peut-être aller voir marquant parce
que ça fait un moment qu'on n'a pas été
on n'a pas été le voir
est-ce que ça doit un souffre d'avoir le
wat y penser à faire les lancements
et du cou
e
[Musique]
alors alors bayer au début j'avais pas
la position en train de jouer la petite
finale ils ont passé le
faisait il ya pas eu beaucoup
d'évolutions rupture est à la rigueur
les pions sont tous symétrique le fou
contre le gâchis cavaliers
moi je pense à inferno oui mais voilà
alors le mans ce sera un joli résumé
quand même quand on voit le parcours
quasi sans faute de derrida ici on vous
rappelle qu'on était dans cette position
là on disait déjà que ça allait
peut-être faire nul et a préféré de 115
ans et 6 pour pas se le faire enlever de
la case des cinq
est solide
ouais
il n'y a pas eu de
aucun des cinq et je pense qu'eric asie
il veut gagner mais
a marre qu'on va se va se battre dans
cette position est ce que c'est pas un
peu plus facile à jouer côté beauté
noire quand même sous fin j'ai
l'impression
de la gagne âge
n'en reviens pas ses droits
non qu'est-ce que tu joues en fait
on sait pas les i'm not on pourra y
revenir de façon mais donc je préfère
les voir les ags notch et parce que tu
en penses touffe mais
me dis que j'ai peut-être plus
d'améliorations de roy autre chose comme
ça à ce que j'espère faire quoi
ouais bon c'est clair alors oui je pense
qu'on va peut-être se prépare-t-il ya un
deck not
track
et en plus l'entrée sur 15 novembre 13
636 mais prague france c'est mieux parce
que la partie et les plus chaudes en moi
plus chaudes mais j'ai l'impression qu'à
ça tombe comme un château de cartes en
saas effondrement
bah je pense aussi la jeunesse dans
prend h7 mais il ya peut-être des
problèmes de foot pro f 5 suroît g8 aux
siens
5 8 6 et dames g5 au marché
ça a l'air pas mal en tout cas
intéressant il aurait fallu vérifier
elle a
failli avoir des problèmes peut-être
2.951 terme des fois je suis comme tout
candidat aussi
moi je suis dit adam dire je suis là
je suis tout jeune des huit qui
h5 il appartient à chaque
classe est très très très tendue pour
west and co qui fait la moue ouais à
cela faire coller à la dernière ronde
par le petit ça fait mal
ou g5 bien joué nous l'a souvent f5
et si le père et des bougies ou aux sept
voix c'est la chaussée c'est ceux-là
voilà c'est tout de suite même peut-être
abandon
d'anne-cécile s'agit cette
célébration non mais la fouille de
recettes 12 tours 7 itou qui déconne là
quand on commence à craquer
non c'est plus on sait plus comment
dirais-je
jouer
vous n'avez pas spoiler le arbitres qui
se met devant
tous bien vu
hélas dur dur
or ici parce qu il a plus de temps on va
peut-être aller voir une autre partie
parce que vois je sais pas ce que tu en
penses souffre mais là vous allez voir
on peut on peut tourner entre ventre
rester et oprag pendant que le death
note à la quine s'est terminée le zaï
notes et gros avantage mais elle va
gagner
dur dur vie dit sa fin de tournoi
horrible et 20 de forest alors
oui 36ème c'est pas vraiment ça y note
il reste quatre coups à jouer en 8
minutes
pas très rigolo
on croise 5 donc là il va y avoir un roi
f4 peut-être abandonné
essayer d'aller bon alors aux écritures
à 3,4
il y aurait trois ou quatre matches mais
ça c'est la belle bêtise à faire
regarder
termine a
fait cette production à cause d'un but
parce que final le fou et f3 il est mais
il est bloqué par les pions à tomber
trois blocs d'options b et du coup à
tour eu de regret sur le plan b
et en fait les noirs sont hyperactifs
pas mal car la défense qui l'a trouvée
sans quoi un jeu il ya six mois je
croyais pas
en fait bien tranquille
non pas six pas si facile moment de
passer un par wade 6 être joué
parce que j'ai comme plan
au passage
il a fait roi f6 et parois des 6 un peu
étonné de cette prise de décision
moi je recommande à 6
elle est pâle et en d6 pour contrôler
tous les cases de l'échiquier
mais rodez ça me paraissait plus
instinctif
à l'explication de ce roi et fils tout
fait ce que tu là toi de ton côté ben
non moi je te fait roi 2 6 1
c'est pas trop que de dire sur le roi
est coupée
mais bon les gens n'ont pas trente six
coups non plus un nom
tu vas suroît g3 il y aura h5
ils sont privés g4 tactique
du club des 3
5/5 et peut-être
est-ce que tu pense qu'une nul peut être
possible entre
cinq tours 2-3 heures 6 tours se
répète
répétition en tout cas
[Musique]
pas très rigolo
donc prague il s'est passé quoi [ __ ] 5
m6 la marche les voir
moi j'avais en même temps que tu peux
évoluer mais bon c'est histoire de
tourner parce que là
ça part en retraite et il se passe pas
grand chose donc c'est plus rigolo
madame d'un me 3 j'imagine
dames 1 3 il y aura d'amd septième parmi
eux trois
il y avait un faux problème s'inquiète m
ah c'est donc du coup il a joué
qu'il a joué à fond ses huit pour
défendre le point f5
alors comment on finit le travail ici
à me 3 puis on peut ramener le foie
jeu 3g 4g
carte là c'est pas bête
en fait sur quatre souffre pour finir le
match et quatre pions je dois mes fins
ouais
davantage radamès trois ans peut-être
tour f1 plutôt oui et samarie champions
3 1 à 9,7 watchguard salahi pertes
forains mais attention j'ai qu'après
faut baisser
ouais mais en fait une menace rien je
crois horrible gf
je ferai deux
bouts
j'écarte gagne là un très joli gain pour
finir la rupture
mais j'ai cassé le groupe
regardez le petit prague ce genre de
cours va peut-être trouvé un autre bien
encore plus sûres j'écarte déjà ça a
l'air d'être
d'être un très joli coup en dames 3 pas
dire qu'il a pas jugé 4 et
à trouver peut-être plus raisonnable
toujours faire je crois j'ai quatre
comme ça
contrôlez un petit 2 d'abord n'ont pas
grand chose
dommage qu'il ait pas juger quatre ans
que c'était le coup non
c'était le peut-être le coup un message
beaucoup
quel génie soit +10
il me joly en plus bon mais avant il se
dit j'ai pas besoin de ça peut-être
qu'il a vu un c'est possible et se dit
bon
je finis propre
et je repars chez de jarden alors il a
fait en fait tout ça pour ça
je croyais bien mélanger
et maintenant qu'est ce que j'ai comme
quoi par apa retour ces deux
pour ce 4e tour c'est un rideau ne donne
b2 avec l'idée justement c'est ça l'idée
washam quel malin ouais et c'est encore
un peu de travail
bien joué
il est malin ce petit event soir est
gamin il ya ilahi l'a6 et renoir
il a forcé le roi noir d'aller d'aller
sur la case des six pour après pouvoir
manger h 6 sur l'échelle de clyde nb2
pas je pense par exemple au betis est
maintenant peut-être je jouais avec b 4
fois
ça permet de continuer
mais bon ça doit pas être facile à
gagner quand même un
an ça à faire mieux quand même souffert
de travail c'est ça ouais il a pas le
nom mais
quelque chose comme ça
assurément
les petits prague on a toujours
c'est tour prend b2 tourache un
tour b 6
donc on affiche 3,5
on va retourner alors donc tu veux faire
quoi je mange je mange
way est tombé 6
et 3 au 5 juin thé l'ordre pris 0,5
et
tout racheter un coef 4
tu manges mais si je mange là je bouge
montre ou
être fou à quatre avec four b3 peut-être
pourquoi n'en at 6 3 6
parce que maintenant mine de rien ggabgo
3 1
tu peux refaire -5 attend peut-être
juste i hope that use est fou c'est 2
tu vois jouer ça
et de forcer n'en souffre
ouais alors logique en tout cas
je veux gagner tu aimeras vous
moquez
d'accise du coup
bon ok food et 3 octobre et 3 orge pas
et ça en fait à phu bien par bolt a pas
de bol c'est la pire cache quoi tu te
prendre sept
mois des produits non mais c'était bien
c'était illégal
justice c'est bon quoi
mais il ya encore tout eu peu de
pression et pense que c'est mais je dois
pas perdre je me sens donné à chis web
peut-être tu gardes 58 ans est solide
après si je connais sont bons ce trophée
finalement c'est le regarde une fois en
plus en plus une fois que la pourrait-on
lâchant quand tu voulais deltour bay 6-5
dans plus tu menaces croire airways 4
noir c'est bon ça paraît mieux ça et du
coup là je trouve dans les jupes à deux
il ya plus de trois quatre matches
sauvées si je jouais pour rester dans la
même ossature champions il a dû comparer
les deux les deux ont l'air de faire nul
hein je suis d'accord avec stouff mais
cette position c'est la position qu'il a
pu le départ il la connaît bien l'air de
bien revenir il voit pas trop comment
vont forez à passer du coup il la garde
c'est logique
alors on va juste jeter un oeil à la
victoire de prague au sud de prague le
prague sobre bang prague est qui qui bat
on voit qu'il a plus le temps un du tout
aussi penco
tombe à jouer
donc on sait pas combien de temps ils en
pensent quoi on voit pas sur la caméra
ni rien mais a beaucoup sans doute mais
on sait qui a très très peu de temps il
sait qu'il est foutu les refuges et qu'à
tout à l'heure et je sais pas ce que je
joue à il a juste une seule envie c'est
de finir
est pas une malle autant
dans me2 ça évite tout cas dépensé 3
bientôt il y aura des h3g cap dam des
huit en tout cas c'est un très
intéressant de frei la fully la ficam de
bonnes perfs
c'était dur pour lui un meilleur mais
quand tu regardes quand même prague